Hello, hello,
hi, hi, hi, hi, someone probably, oh my goodness, happy birthday, happy, happy birthday!
Today, we're spooky, spooky, spooky!
Yeah!
You guys like my witches hat?
Um, I thought, wait, not I thought.
um hold on wait my words i today today today before i before i before i get so uh why am i so twisty tied today why am i so twisty i don't know how to words anymore um i uh thank you whimsy so much for the five gifted uh today i'll be playing a couple briefly because it's like i have no set one thing i'm doing i feel like i have so many things i'm doing i i i um i will be playing uh a couple random horror games today right now is uh what's it called oh my gosh next fest on steam which is like you get a bunch of they just they there's a bunch of demos and um you know i've and other people before play like random indie horror game kind of type things and i was like oh well i've always wanted to do that like maybe from itchio um or something like that but um i thought maybe this would also be a good chance to try some other types of games because they're like demos so we'll know for sure that they're not too long and i think i got a couple of interesting
um they should all work hopefully um but i just wanted to start getting into some spooky games because it's october and so i really wanted to play some spooky stuff and well oh my gosh originally i was just like if i play a bunch of random games i can cross off a bunch of you know maybe three or four games or something um off my list of games i need to beat but because these are all demos i guess that doesn't count huh i guess i kind of screwed myself out of that thinking yeah demos don't count boo that's okay though that's okay we're just here to have fun and if we like the games one of them for sure i kind of want to play not kind of i do want to play um because it's the first game we'll be playing some of you guys might recognize some of these games or at least yeah you might not the games but i'm not gonna play granny i'm not but you know what i like to watch is granny speed runs i like watching granny speed runs they're so funny but um yeah so um i'm not taking requests for games
though because i already have the ones that i have downloaded And if they don't work for whatever reason, I'm just going to go find something else off of Steam, another demo.
So that horror slop game.
You guys know Granny, right?
It's like, how do you describe?
I feel like there was like a type of game that spawned.
You know how games spawned from like PT and FNAF, like similar games.
Happy Thanksgiving in Canada.
Happy Thanksgiving in Canada!
I feel like a granny also spawned a certain kind of game.
But I don't know what it's called.
Mobile horror.
Escape room type horror.
That sounds correct.
So basically granny is like one of those games.
It's a game where you are in this grandma's house.
And you have to kind of do like escape room type puzzles to escape grandma.
And there's multiple ways to escape.
and like you'll be like oh i go downstairs and i find a screwdriver and the screwdriver unlocks this and that gives me a battery and then i put the battery in this and what are those types of games where it's like a step by step but the the the uh items are randomized so you know the screwdriver won't always be in the same place it's kind of got like a bit a level of replayability and every noise you make like if you accidentally if you like unlock a thing granny will hear it kind of thing kind of like that neighbor game yes yes yes yes yes it's like that wow what was that called I don't remember time to ask the age old question BA polls good
anyway anyway hello neighbor yeah so um but that we're not playing granny today that game stresses me out too i like it's one of those games i like watching people play it but i don't want to play it because i'm gonna be like
anyway um i have four games today the first one is one that i am looking forward to playing and it's because i've kind of beside from zombie games that i've been on a bit of a binge i'm i'm also i'm also a big fan of of fishing games happy halloween rito i'm gonna visit my gf for the first time on saturday and i'm so excited we live in different countries so good have fun and then watch my streams with her you know uh yeah so fishing games and this one is did you guys know that um that chilla's art is coming out with a fishing horror game so we're gonna play that first um i also should mention i didn't open like any of these games because i knew i was going to have to um re adjust like resize them all and do all that fun stuff so we're just gonna do it live baby let's go um oh hi eggplant me Hi,
Eric.
Let's see.
All right.
We're doing it live.
You might hear the game first.
Oh, wow.
What the hell?
Why is it?
Why is the resolution?
Oh, things are loading in the screen.
As I'm...
Okay.
project boat the game is called oh here it is okay it looks way better for you guys than it does for me that's fine I'll just go right here um on my screen the game is like so small for some reason I'll move you guys over okay alright let's try try umigani i don't know how so long any of these games are um so uh what was i gonna say oh that boat just loaded in what's going on
um uh yeah um i don't know how long any of these demos are so if we you know play all four games that i have downloaded i need to play i need to download something else that's all good Oh yeah, oh, there we go.
Umigaria, let's play.
Oh, there is an options for it.
You know what?
I'm just gonna keep it as...
Wait, no.
I'm gonna turn off.
Maybe not.
Do nothing in Ultra.
Also, frame rate...
Limit.
Limit?
There should be a limit?
Oh, whoa.
Okay.
It says what?
We have zero frames.
FPS?
FPS means frames per sometimes I guess 60 why is it a slider that's that's the good question let's see um we'll just go with this for now apply control we'll just we'll see how it goes have my birthday last weekend Now I'm celebrating it tonight with my wife.
Serval!
Happy birthday!
Fancy stew!
So this is a demo, everybody.
Please keep in mind that all these games are demos.
So if they are, you know, of the scuffed variety, if they're a little, you know, if they're not as polished, we're not going to be so judgmental because they are demos.
And that's kind of also why I wanted to choose demos rather than like some uh like some of the shorter indie horror games because you know if like you know i try not to be so negative when someone is making a game i can't i don't know how to do that they're they're doing better than i am so yeah we'll we'll but if something's real bad we could say it's bad because it's a demo yeah i can't judge i can't make game i mean either objective get to school with my No,
no, no, no, catch fish, selfish, refuel.
That's how we get to school?
Fast travel.
Oh, my gosh.
We have a green conch.
Oh, I took it.
And it gave me 100 yen.
It's...
What the hell?
Wait a second.
We have, like, forest gump over here.
200 yen.
We can run.
300 yen this feels so not chill as art 400 yen this is actually so interesting from their normal stuff i wonder where the vtubers are
hello oh god you oh oh gosh he's sick oh he's sick in the head too i can i really can shoot this He looks like a fish.
He's become what he sells.
He's so scary.
Welcome.
What?
This looks so different from like regulars chillas are.
Am I crazy?
Back in my day we had to catch sharks and sell them to pay for bus tickets to get to school.
Oh, you're out hunting?
Very nice.
If you catch something here and leave it on the boat, I'll buy it.
Don't drive rough though, the fish will fall out.
you'll only find pufferfish here but I've seen big ones pulled up from these waters before bring me the goodies and I'll upgrade your boatie my boatie you'll be out there in no time am I going to school what how old am I bring me a load all right oh wow there's Wow okay harpoon range boat speed we are upgrading and selling.
Wow.
Okay.
Interesting.
And then our Noriba.
So if I...
You think I'll get something big?
No.
Wait, what's that?
More money.
Wait, what if I...
Oh, I can swim.
Fish!
I also can just breathe underwater.
This is the most effective way of being a fisherman.
Nice hat.
Thank you.
Happy Halloween, everybody.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
That's not a puffer fish.
I think he lied.
I feel kind of bad for him.
Okay, here's my alive fish.
Brought some.
Let me see.
Uh, I did?
I think.
How do I...
What do I do with this guy?
I could drop him.
Oh my god, he's humongous!
Oh my gosh!
I've just been casually...
Oh my god!
I don't think he's alive anymore.
Put it in my box.
How do I do that?
Oh, I have to put it in the boat, he said, maybe.
Is that it?
Get on boat.
Oh, selling.
Place your catch inside the green frame to sell it.
Ah, items not placed in the frame will disappear after a while.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, look at me cow.
I think he's wrong.
It's not just puffer fish.
Whoa!
What's out over there?
Giant windmills.
Well, there's lots of fish here.
Wait, are these the puff- oh, these must be the puffer fish.
Ah!
Oh, dang!
I think I got him.
I don't think that guy is alive anymore.
Are you guys feeling spooky?
Oh, he's all puffed up.
I want to go out boating and stuff.
Wait, how does it sell?
Hmm.
I got a big guy.
First try.
Oh.
Did you guys... Oh, I passed out.
Oh, my gosh.
I was about to say, do you guys have the salacisophobia?
Yeah, I keep thinking of that pufferfish, like, sound the oh you know that guy's glowing fear of open waters yeah yeah yeah holy cow oh my gosh what are these guys eating wait there's an island over there another one and then what's over here oh nothing can i sell you you now ah here we go here we go Sell.
Oh, select all.
Sell.
Today's my birthday.
Call it.
Happy birthday.
Being awesome at introducing me to Dave the Diver and Dredge.
I love fishing games like this.
Okay, we sold fish.
Now we refuel.
Oh, okay.
Expensive.
Okay, we go to school.
Where the hell is school?
School is not on the map.
I'm guessing it's that over there, no?
What if I get trapped in the middle of the ocean?
Look at the size of these things!
Oh.
What?
What's peeping?
Low fuel!
Okay, I think I gotta sell more stuff.
We're not gonna make it.
We're not gonna make it!
Am I doing the sound?
right oh like the puffer fish oh oh okay we need to get some more big boys this guy is ripe for the picking hey this guy took my kill okay wait can i do no only one at a time
drop all right come here big boy what it's so violent whoa this guy's huge he's like when he's right behind me it's kind of insane holy cow
our goldfish our pufferfish like goldfish and that like you know how like some goldfish will grow to be super big like they kind of grow to the size of their bowl tank.
I wonder if Pufferfish are the same.
Okay, so we should probably fill up our tank.
Let's try and get... Oh, this guy over... Oh, that freaks me out every time.
Let's try and get this guy over here.
Ah!
Huh?
Okay.
There, this guy.
Dang.
I like how I basically have to be in the water, though, to catch these fish.
Um, can I go out just a little bit further?
Alright, we might black out.
The sun is in my eyes.
But the wind is...
My sails...
Wait, the fish is in my heart.
Ha!
You know, like, the wind is in my sails.
I don't know what I'm trying to say.
Don't...
You sucker!
What?
Because, well, I'm trying to say that I can do it.
I don't know, I don't know, I actually didn't even see how much he sold for.
Hello.
They don't sell for very much.
Isn't, like, Fugu a delicacy?
I think many people will pay top dollar for these fine, fine pufferfish.
Oh my god.
The tuna was like 70?
Oh, so even less?
Ah, okay.
Maybe we don't want him then.
Oh, one of them was 750!
Ah, okay.
Maybe it was him then.
We do want this guy.
Okay, I'm gonna try.
We might black out.
Okay, we blacked out.
Alright, I know the point of no return.
Yeah, we got him, we got him!
Ooh.
Whoa.
Alright, don't flop out.
Oh my gosh, he's really...
He's really big.
Ah!
Wait!
What's up?
Um, guys, I think I broke the game.
Guys, I think I broke the game.
Oh, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it.
I think?
We do have him, right?
I was just trying to get him in this spot.
So he doesn't despa- Okay, let's go sell it.
Let's see if he sells.
Please, please.
A thousand!
That's less than ten bucks.
Nice.
Oh, nice shot, Minto.
Thanks, Minto.
Oh, this is tiny.
Tiny, tiny guy.
Okay.
They can't all be winners, I suppose.
Uh-oh.
We eventually do have to play the other game, so I can't spend all my time fishing.
But what if?
This guy is...
I can't get over how big these fish are.
They're so large.
Or can you?
Alright, what I'm gonna do is also...
This is a horror game.
It is.
What if I fast...
Hajimari... Oh, okay.
I'm guessing Hajimari Island is over there.
Do you guys see that?
You guys see that, right?
Oh.
What is that?
That's a big boy.
Wait, he's like so close, though.
That's a big, big boy.
Wait, we can go see him.
All right, max fuel.
Alright, bye!
There he is.
What if I...
He's kind of fast though.
But what if I catch him?
Okay, let's uh, let's go this way instead.
Let's go to the other island.
Oh!
You can open or close the map with the M key.
This is already... this doesn't feel like a Chillizard game, does it?
I kind of want to keep fishing!
Look at this!
What's this?
Emergency button.
Leave your cargo here and return to the last gas station you visited, okay?
Oh, whoops.
How do I cancel?
Wait.
Cancel.
Cancel?
Oh, space.
My bad.
I don't want to jump in because I'm afraid I will pass out.
I guess it would just put me back on the boat.
Where'd that big tuna go?
Oh, well.
Where'd that other big guy go?
Spooky, spooky, scary.
Oh, wait.
Yeah!
Come here.
You're mine.
And it said don't go too fast.
Holy cow!
Or the fish drop out.
And we need them to have a good education.
They can't be dropping out of school.
to have good grades.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Oh.
It's a...
A shrine?
Whoa.
Ah, half fuel.
Okay, thank you.
Hello?
Girl in school uniform.
She's cute!
She's so cute!
I have to get to the island.
I have to end the curse before I...
Before what?
Someone has to do it.
Will you please help me get to the island?
Oh.
Oh, she's just on my boat!
Okay.
Free girlfriend?
More money?
I'm robbing from...
from the shrine?
She's gonna fish out, you guys.
It's kind of relaxing here, though.
How'd you get out here?
Hmm.
Any good fish around here?
Little lady?
She swam.
I like how...
This seems like a world that...
Oh, this is...
Did you guys ever watch Weathering with you?
this is what happened she's like staring at me just swimming around with my harpoon she wouldn't cross me though I have a harpoon what island I didn't I need a map this is my map oh sorry I keep pressing escape just a girl in her your uniform looks a little wet you're gonna get sick like that she's so cute guys oh my gosh remember how chill as art games looked back in the day now we have girls as cute as this let's go back and refuel and also maybe um what's the word
and get some upgrades maybe.
Big boy.
Yeah!
You're like...
You're like fat boys.
I suppose it is a sailor uniform.
You're my first matey.
Holy cow!
She's like, I love pufferfish.
Oh, ma'am.
The curse can wait.
A delicious meal for you, my queen.
Free sushi.
All right, it's not free.
Don't don't don't get it twisted.
Wait, you, you, you, you, you, you, where'd you go?
That guy's humongous.
Yeah!
Nice shot, me!
Oh, oh.
Okay, we gotta go back.
Oh,
overboard!
Wait, she left something.
Fuel max range.
Wait, what?
Treasure?
Oh, my gosh, she left the treasure map.
My girlfriend is so awesome.
Man overboard!
Oh, my god.
Maybe she is a fish now.
This guy scares me, and he's like, Poffing up along for real.
All right.
All my fish are still rolling around.
Hello, sir.
Shell.
Really?
I feel like that one was, like, exceptionally huge.
All right.
Upgrade.
Let's see what we got.
Fuel capacity, boat speed.
Let's do a little speed.
Harpoon speed.
Harpoon range.
Speed.
And we have Maybe enough to fuel Fill up
Yes Came here for horror And send mince fishing Um our girl just Just just jumped I think that's pretty scary Alright so which way we go in then To the treasure And then there's also another guy over that way Alright cool So, but this way is where we need to go to treasure,
right?
Yeah.
Oh, we're going this way.
All right.
I think she was a siren, yeah.
Lord be in with her sweet, sweet voice.
Okay, good.
We're not losing
gas like crazy right now.
She was giving fish.
Oh, the merchant though.
Have you seen that guy?
Oh, some of them are, like, broken.
You see that?
Wait, I don't...
Holy moly!
Ow!
Too, too strong.
Yeah!
Sorry, buddy.
Gosh, there's...
giant.
How am I only getting a thousand yen for this stuff?
I swear, someone's ripping me off, for real.
I see this... Okay, so it says we're like right on the island.
Maybe I need to go here a little bit.
Some of these aren't working.
Or the treasure, rather.
I guess it's not quite an island.
I'm scared of what the horror is going to be like in this game.
Oh!
Oh wait!
I see that!
Half fuel.
We're okay.
Treasure?
Huh?
I fixed it!
I'm a hero!
There's another one!
Wait, is this blood or...
But it looks like this one has something on the other...
Okay.
Sure is starting to look very silent.
Hill in here.
What's that?
Oh, that's the big fish.
Wait.
Come back, big fish.
Okay, he's kind of fast.
Alright, we gotta save this one too.
I'm a hero.
Yeah, there's a fish up there.
Hey!
Mind the fuel.
Yeah, we'll be okay, I think.
Yeah!
Is that guy mine?
How do you get speared so perfectly like that?
Where's the treasure?
Did I get scammed?
She wouldn't.
I've known her for all of two minutes, but surely she wouldn't.
Oh, dang it.
Spear the fish?
Yeah, I'm trying.
We'll get her next time, boys.
Why is...
Why are other...
Why?
I have questions.
Ah!
That felt so close.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm just...
Okay, here we go.
Here he comes.
NT, thank you.
Ah!
I give up.
White circle in the water.
Oh, that?
the very obvious thing that i definitely didn't see right in front of my face
what is that recently brought new electric guitar light blue fender oh it's in desperate need of a name a name oh sorry scared me can i grab that oh we're getting beat up a little bit I have a sonar!
Oh, ouch.
Uh-oh.
Guys, we're low on fuel.
A name for a blue guitar.
Am I going the right way?
About.
I think so.
Oh, we're about to die.
Oh.
I blacked out.
Oh!
Wait, it's totally fine.
Blue guitar.
My fish, I lost him, yeah.
It's fine, I'll get a new one.
I'm still thinking.
Wait, spearmint would be kind of great for a name.
Spearmint for your guitar.
Sounds yummy.
all right so we know that there's an island over this way so let me sell a little bit let me get a couple fish and then we'll go the real horror is capitalism because we're having to to buy our way to to go around and do anything getting a job was the real horror of the game Wait,
can I spear more than one fish?
Getting a jab.
Yeah.
Wait.
All right, maybe this is good enough.
Oh, wait.
My fuel is max, but I still want a little bit more, like, you know.
Sell.
Select all.
Okay.
Let's go.
To further ventures.
So I'm going to go.
Am I going the right way?
Kind of.
We need to go a little more this way, I believe.
Yes, okay.
Onwards!
Chill with the J word.
You're scaring me.
Sorry.
Sorry, I'm supposed to be a channel where you forget your responsibilities.
And here I am bringing up such terrible concepts.
Don't even worry.
pretty little head, okay?
Wow, this is far!
Are we gonna make it?
Spearminto!
Sounds awesome!
Thank you very much, Pinto fellows.
Yeah!
Enjoy your guitar!
Okay, I don't think we can be distracted by anything.
No distractions!
We are on course to the location.
I'm already here.
Ah!
No distractions.
That's an animal.
Do you think we'll make it?
I guess we'll see.
Leviathan.
I know.
I feel like I'm playing dredge all over again.
You will not.
What?
Have faith!
We'll just keep going forward!
look trees trees trees we're so close we are so uh oh we're so close please please I gotta get to school big fish bottom right we're so close oh my gosh it's literally in my oh no I'm gonna black out.
I'm about to pass out.
I'm about to black out.
Please.
I was right here.
You son of a bitch.
You.
We are so close, you guys.
That sucks.
Okay.
We have to get more upgrades.
Luckily, that's why I also didn't catch anything, because I was like, I'm not gonna waste my time.
Need one more upgrade.
Yep.
Okay, Chillas aren't so stingy.
Hello!
Oh, there you are.
I don't know how I managed to get that, but...
This is a Chillas game?
It is!
Isn't that crazy?
Honestly, I feel like I could play this just the whole...
Oh, okay.
Let me sell them real quick.
Okay.
Oh, yeah!
Wait, okay, so upgrade, fuel capacity.
I'm gonna upgrade the speed as well.
So let's get a couple more.
But yeah, this is a Chillas Arc game.
That's why I was so interested in it, because I'm like, oh my gosh.
It's a fish game.
It's a fish horror game.
And also...
Dang, not that far away.
Um, it's so different from what they usually put out.
I was very interested, you know.
Yeah.
There's one game that I am excited to try to, though, that I downloaded earlier that I think will be kind of funny.
So, we'll see what it's like.
Um, so...
That's it.
500?
Okay, we need still another 500 to get to...
upgrade to get the last upgrade we need but i don't want to be like on zero money so we'll get a couple more tuna
okay where were the backer cameos that's what i was wondering i was wondering where the i should probably put like what game we're playing i'll link them below in the description uh after stream since it's a variety of stuff.
I had a nickel for every fishing horror game that you played where capitalism is a true horror and I'm zero nickels being no!
Your nickels!
Oh yeah, I have no fuel too, so we need to fill up.
We need to fill up, fill up, fill up, baby.
Alright.
Alright, let's catch a couple of these guys because they're all right here too, you know.
more money
holy cow god oh my gosh sucks for anybody who hates fish and plays this game you know
like i understand the fear like the the the phasophobia fear you know not phasmophobia but like the fear of open water because like Like, you're swimming, and there could be a really big fish underneath your feet, and you would never know.
Like, at the same time.
Oh, this is kind of nice, but we need to fill up.
At the same time, I don't know.
Just kind of, the ocean's kind of relaxing to me.
Yippee!
Okay, now we can go.
On the road again.
I can't wait to be on the road again.
Does the fish fear you?
Oh, yeah.
Can you also link your October Limited merch?
Haven't seen the link?
Yeah.
Oh, I have to find the link.
Sorry.
I'm so bad at merch.
Waking up to Lilac Mint.
I wipe my brow, and I sweat my what?
Are you okay?
Are you half asleep?
This game scares me because I can't swim.
to learn how to swim, Phil.
Knowing how to swim is so important, you guys.
Don't pass up learning how to swim.
Hi, Minto.
Oh, hio.
Wait, we're already half-fueled?
Oh, but we're, like, closer.
Maybe.
You never know when you need to know how to swim, too.
It's, like, super duper important.
Okay.
Sorry, I thought I heard something.
I heard like a creek on my boat.
My bathtub does not scare me.
I know how to swim, yes I do.
I did not die by drowning.
What is that?
That's a fast fish.
He looks like he's worth a lot of money.
I'll take you.
Wait!
wait um guys my fish has a seifuku wait um okay we're just gonna keep going
wait all these fish have seifuku
wait what
i wish i could find where the gas is before i run out i don't want to make this trek again please don't make me oh no no no oh gosh am i gonna to make it?
I think we technically made it.
I'm just gonna hop the fence.
Okay, I think we've found the horror maybe.
Wait, there's a person up there.
I made it to school!
This really is what happens after weathering with you.
It's actually so peaceful, though.
Except all the fish Are girls No, we don't think it's a witch or the pit, thank you
What's that sound?
Oh, no, this is scary I don't like that I don't like that one bit What is this?
GPS Oh my god, the door shuts by itself Scary Scary Wait, that's a fish.
Oh, it's just fish.
They look a little aggressive, though, no?
Ah!
Okay.
Chill out, chill out!
Class is in session!
They zoom in, yeah.
But wait, with the wind chimes, it's so nice.
This feels kind of nice.
the lighting is pretty freaky it's freaking me out a little bit it's like nice and scary at the same time we gotta go talk to this guy whoever he is i can't believe this is a chillas art game i'm like actually so like the desks in a circle okay scary like they've come so far from their previous games
This is like so scary and so relaxing at the same time.
I don't know...
You know when you're like scared and turned on?
That's how I feel right now.
But not turned on.
Just relax.
It's kind of like a conflicting, you know, feeling.
Ready for clash?
Oh, senpai!
It's my birthday!
Leia, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Ah, here we go.
Wait.
What is that of...
What is that of big...
What was that actually?
Was that I don't know what that...
Guys?
Okay.
Look at all that money he's hoarding.
Um...
Okay.
Can I get him?
Let's try.
Oh.
Dang.
I don't think so.
No, I can't.
Once again, that feeling, you know what I was just talking about?
Like, can we get to him from up here?
No!
Stinking way!
Okay, wait.
Let's go talk to this guy first.
We're gonna get his ass.
And I'm gonna sell him.
Look at all this money?
Wait.
These are people's things.
Ah!
Oh, gosh!
Oh,
I am reborn.
God didn't abandon me.
There were bullies in my class.
because I was always watching them from the fish tank.
Some classmates were kind to me.
They even fed me through the glass.
But the bullies tormented the ones who cared for me.
I'm part of the class too.
I'll make sure those jerks are dealt with.
You see the desks in front of me?
Yeah.
They're the accessories the bullies wear.
Can I take their stall for?
Guys, I think this game's...
a little freaky i'm afraid though i think i'm so out of fuel we won't be able to make it to the gas station even though i've gone here we'll we'll keep exploring and then we'll pass out
so there's so much happening in this game the world is flooded and girls people are turning into fish and fish are turning into people and everything is confusing wait oops
that's awkward nobody saw that
i don't think i can shoot it
he must want you to go back and harpoon bullies maybe
oh i thought the wind chime stopped for a second Again, I was about to be like, uh-oh.
Did I make somebody angry?
Dog?
Fish?
Oh, more...
More monies.
I feel like the game sometimes gets a little frame rate kind of ugly, sorry.
Maybe I harpoon the bullies and, like, put them here?
Huh.
Alright, well, let's go, um...
Uh, let's go pass out, I guess.
Please let me make it to the...
Oops!
Oh, okay, that's worked.
That works.
Please!
And there we go.
Off-grid!
Chilla's art!
You're so stingy!
These guys only give me, like, 200 yen.
Oh, my goodness.
They're like, you're getting your money's worth from this demo.
It's free!
The demo is free!
Oh!
Oh, dang it, sorry.
Weeks of fun!
Wait.
Am I lost?
Where's the...
No.
Yeah, the tuna should be there.
Okay.
I think there was something closer on the radar.
Like the...
Fueling place?
I don't know.
The radar only shows me fish.
Wait, my GPS, though.
Did that...
Did we lose everything?
I picked up a GPS, didn't I?
Do I have...
Did I lose everything?
No Akasupa's in this game, only floundering.
Fish.
You only have...
few things I enjoy in life.
Fishing, fishing, and minto.
Who is also fishing.
Yeah, we are.
Yeah, we do that.
I think I'm too far.
Oh!
No, I might be a genius!
She's the greatest fisher of this generation.
There's the big guy!
That big lad.
Alright, please.
how much do i need to upgrade wait i can't even upgrade my am i just really bad at this is this the end of the demo wait a second no
way they're like you can't ever get to the other place okay let's try one more time this is just a demo yep yep
What?
Purple?
Wait, purple?
What?
Purple?
Huh?
Wait, huh?
Suddenly purple?
Purple?
I'm purple!
No distractions?
Oh my gosh.
I need to stop slowing down because I think that also, like, lowers my life decimated by ghosts.
What's the orpul?
What's the red button do?
It's like an emergency button where if you...
Yeah.
That.
Big fish.
No distractions.
We're already halfway, guys.
I see you.
Landhole!
Where was the school at?
You just need to not go to the school.
Wait, I think I'm in the right direction.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay!
It was just me being bad at the game.
What a surprise!
No, no, don't say that.
Don't say that, don't say that, don't say that, don't say that.
We're almost there.
We're like, we're so close.
Please, please, please don't, please, let me live!
I think I need to...
Oh, we did it!
Uh, dock.
We did it!
Gas, gas, gas.
Maybe this guy has more upgrades.
Oh, so you managed to get here.
Way to go!
Rasm, let me see.
No.
Oh, no, he doesn't either.
Okay, I guess there will be more upgrades.
in the demo or in the full game but because demo very limited okay so there's no crouch in here in this so I can't go into the store it doesn't seem like there's anything in there anyway maybe in the full game oh oh that's kind of
That's kind of freaky.
Does this...
Wait.
What's that on fire over there?
Does this sell for anything?
Fish heck.
Heck yeah!
Nice.
Is that my old boat?
Now we can travel safely because...
Wait, they just left it there?
No, there's somebody else on...
Nope.
My old...
My old boat?
Oh my gosh, wait!
My girlfriend's still there!
Are you okay?
Okay, now we take her...
onto this boat.
Okay, cool.
Do all the fish around here have Seifuku?
Because if so, this is the best game ever!
Oh.
Don't be shy, baby girl.
Um.
I see some on my radar.
Do I need to...
I don't think I can get in the water.
Oh, wait.
Oops.
We're living on the edge.
I think that's one right there.
I'm going off instinct.
Pure instinct.
Failed me.
But I see one over there.
Oh.
This one?
Uh...
What the...
Who bought you that?
Uh-huh.
So, now what is the orpul about?
You know?
Interesting.
This game is so fascinating to me already.
I'm so, like, curious about everything right now.
This guy also has an ugly shirt.
Clearly the Seifuku fish are the most desirable.
I can't believe my ship is here.
That's so funny.
I don't know what else to do though.
Again it just says go to school.
We did that though.
No?
Didn't we?
Like we totally went to school.
Is this not school?
Oh, it's on my fish.
Tibid, timid fish.
Hi, lilac mint.
Hello.
How do I know how to get the bullies, though?
You think they're...
You think they're like...
The ones in the classrooms?
Or something?
Can I get in the water here?
Oops.
Same accessories as the ones on the...
Oh, true!
True, true, true.
Let's try.
Did you hear that?
Um.
Wait.
The door is an opening?
I can't tell if it has an accessory or not.
I'll just drop it.
Oh, he's dead.
It has clothes on, I think.
Maybe it's that one that is lit up.
That would make sense, huh?
Oh, yeah, it is!
It is!
Oh my god.
My boat on fire in the distance!
It's so ominous!
happens when we get all the bullies then.
I noticed the ones glowing earlier and I was kind of just like...
Oops.
I was like...
I couldn't tell if it was the lighting or not, you know?
Oh my gosh, she's so fast.
Okay, we got her.
Why does the door close on me?
It's kind of annoying, actually.
I feel like it's setting me up for some sort of jump scare.
as fast as me though exactly so
are they people or were they fish and fish turning into people everything is so mysterious right now did I do this classroom I think so these guys seem fine they're not so frantic why am I a human why are there some humans these
guys are a little freaky oh wait i think that's okay maybe in here
no we're looking we're looking we're searching in here maybe did i did you guys see where the last guy was
too dark i know it's very dark right it's hard for even me to Let the lead that lives in your heart tell you if they're people or not.
What is that supposed to mean?
I don't know if I can go downstairs.
I think it's too flooded, no?
Yeah, too flooded.
Good thought, though.
Good idea.
Winter Espa fam.
Welcome back.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Am I crazy?
It's payball!
Does any of you have a cute little accessory?
Am I missing a classroom?
Oh, there was a...
Here.
But it's so dark.
I can't see anything.
Open the door, please!
Thank you.
Yeah, the GPS is gone.
Hmm.
I don't think it's the purple part, right?
be the purple thing, no?
Oops, I didn't mean to jump.
Like, what's the color of the last accessory?
Unless.
No, I don't think so.
I don't know!
Where is she?
Nice job.
Do the same for others.
Where, though?
Where?
why is she purple it's because it's spooky season what do you mean why i just wanted to be dressed up is that such a problem am
i a fish person am i supposed to be down here okay no oops i missed
we debunk that real quick
I wanted to be spooky.
What's so wrong with wanting to be spooky, huh?
Whoa!
That was a lot of money.
We're at 9,000 yen, everybody.
Rags to riches story over here.
I have no idea.
I'm about to give up, honestly.
Because I don't want to...
But I want to see the demo through to the end.
You know what I mean?
But if I can't find it, I don't know what to do.
If I can't find the last fish, what am I supposed to do, you know?
Check a guide?
I doubt there's guides, because this is just a demo.
Who's cuter?
Lilac or Minto?
Don't answer that.
Alright, we might just call it here then, and go on to the next game.
I don't want to just keep running around in circles.
I feel like incomplete, but at the same time, it is just a demo, so...
What's Min's favorite type of music?
Any kind with a fresh beat.
What'd that mean?
Did I see something just swim away down there right now?
But yeah, maybe I want to play this once it's actually out.
It seems kind of spooky and fun, so...
We shall play!
the chillas art game uh once it's out yeah
the purple zone is where they are how do you know though how do you know
drive around the school what do we okay fine you guys seem like you want a conclusion as well so we'll I'll satiate your curiosities oops okay
let's get up
we found our boys Oh, and I'm stuck.
There we go.
I got somebody.
My bad.
Collateral damage.
Oh my gosh, she's so freaking fast!
Oh, makes sense.
This is the room that I couldn't get into.
I got her!
Yay!
We can actually complete it maybe.
The lighting goes like crazy in this game, honestly.
Oh, I got her.
Where'd she go?
There she is.
You.
Okay.
All right, come on.
Up to the roof we go.
It feels like it's getting dark and not at the same time.
Is it just me?
All right.
Let's see what happens with our guy up here.
Something's not right.
Aren't these the ones who were getting bullied?
Wait, which is which?
Oh, right, my apologies.
I have the memory of a goldfish, you see.
Either way, the weak must be consumed by the strong, yes?
Just like how I consumed my tank mates.
Now if you'll excuse me.
Oh my gosh, it's far.
Enjoy.
Get to the mall.
How long is this demo?
For real, though.
How long is this?
Okay.
Let's get some upgrades.
Sell this female fish.
For one!
Kenny?
Shut up.
It's okay.
I was going to say I think we could do both, but we really cannot.
I think I need to buy...
I think I need to max out my thing, though.
Oh my gosh.
Am I just going to be playing a demo the entire game?
Entire stream is just demo.
Can you imagine?
That'd be so silly.
Is that fish over there?
No, I don't think so.
Woo, fishing!
It was what?
7,000?
There's got to be some fish around here, no?
I'm going to pass out.
I'm ready to pass.
Fish, fish, fish, fish, fish.
Timid fish, I think.
Those sold for pretty good.
Wait, where'd they go?
Oh, there.
Kind of far, though.
Yay!
Is this a horror game?
I don't know.
fish in seifuku what are you saying you tell me i think for some people this is probably like super unnerving you were planning on playing demos the entire stream no wow demos plural
it's okay we'll we'll get through some don't worry even if it's like a longer stream whatever wait how much was it again seven thousand wait oh i have six thousand okay we need just uh one more fish one more and a little bit extra for some what's it called some fuel and we'll be good to go!
Dang it!
No!
How did you know?
Got him.
This is what they mean, yeah, when they say there's many fish in the sea.
The horror comes in a DLC.
see I crack myself up we
can get more we can get more oh just kidding I pass out somewhere beyond the sea somewhere waiting for me little fish in sailor food I'll catch them my way and we'll go boating.
Wait!
I don't think my range is good enough for that guy.
No, no, no, don't notice me!
You!
Yeah.
It's really satisfying hearing the...
Okay!
DMCA.
Alright, this should be enough money for gas and upgrades.
Oh, my bad.
Uh, yes.
Uh, sell.
Select all.
And gas, please.
Okay.
Alrighty, which way we head into?
It looks far, though.
I'm scared.
My bad.
It looks pretty far.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to face the direction.
Yep.
And we're just going to...
I'm not even going to look at the map.
We're just going to go.
We're going to go, go, go.
Because when I look at the map...
The gas is still going down, but...
But the speed is also going down.
Oh wait, I think I see it already.
The moon!
Oh, the sun is so nice.
something never nobody has ever said before on stream
what a beautiful night random question but do you plan to release your chosen song from the phantom thieves revenge god oh yeah yes yes have you played dredge me though oh yeah i have i have and i played it a lot wait where did the mall go am i crazy it was like right in front of me and then disappeared
yeah i got hooked on hooked on phonics i got hooked on dredge so much uh-oh what's loading in why was there a hiccup in the sound what's going on there's no fish out here
Phantom Mall.
Wait, I think that's it.
What?
What's that?
Wait, what's it?
Oh!
Did you guys see that?
I only caught the tail!
But it's gone.
It's not on our radar anymore.
Is this supposed to be an Aeon Mall?
It kind of looks like a similar logo.
It might fall.
False positive.
Exactly, exactly.
Wait, is that a Daiso?
Aeon malls are very...
Oh my gosh, wait, there's...
Is this supposed to be like, Odaibo?
Or...
Oh no, this is so funny.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, okay, that's the gas thing.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, are we just gonna...
Oh, did you guys see that?
Oh, it's a face!
Ah!
It was a big old head.
We got consumed.
I wanted to make it to the mall.
It looked cute.
Yay!
We did the demo.
Awesome.
Yeah, so that was Umigari, the new Chillas art game coming out.
whenever I guess I don't think there's a I don't think it just says coming soon so cool let's go into the next game that I have which I believe is in English wait where is it there it is okay which is called diruri tachibana reincarnated um which is I guess the English name I don't remember I think it was like Tachibana Niruni something something
Tensei Suru something something I don't know Yeah Uba Jiji I hadn't seen such mass destruction until I saw you What did I do?
Alright let's play the second game then This one This one you'll see why I chose this one Maybe I don't know if you'll see it immediately Or what But It seems kind of funny, so I'm interested.
Oh.
The window for it is so tiny.
Is it going to get big?
Okay.
Ah, eh, ah, eh, ah, eh.
Ah, oh.
Oh.
Wait, this is so strange.
Okay, hold on.
Let me capture it for you guys so you can see it.
It's really small for me, but hopefully it's a deep...
Oh, it's really small for you guys as well.
It's...
Okay!
Stream is starting soon, everybody!
Wait.
Oh, oh, start stream right here, okay?
This is just like OBS!
Wow!
Oh, wow, it's just OBS.
Live rec version.
Okay.
Well, the screen is so small for me.
But, um, recordings.
where will oh settings wait oh i can change the resolution ah ah okay hold on one second you guys oops oh keyboard mouse yes yes okay one second let me we're doing it live we're doing it live we're doing it live okay there we go enhance okay cool and english good good good okay That's so cute that the settings are actually like,
it looks like OBS.
Okay, we have no recordings.
We just have desktop audio on, our avatar, our game capture ready to go.
Chat settings.
Why is it called game stream setting?
Why is it not called like loading screen?
Starting soon.
Okay, star stream.
Hold.
Tachibana, Liruri.
Prism Live, fourth generation.
Acrylic stand!
On sale now!
Wait, it kind of... Wait, this kind of looks like my second outfit, no?
Neruri!
Wait, I'm blocking her.
Hold on.
Wait.
Soaking in my Oshi's voice.
Welcome back, Neruri!
Koen Neruri!
Totally worth waiting and stand by.
What kind of stream is it today?
The BGM feels a bit nostalgic.
Too cute from the start!
Wow!
Akasupa!
Oh,
it's a collab.
Liruli, Tachibana now's a dreamy!
Come, Lirly.
Wow, she's getting so many Akasuba.
She's so popular.
Sparkling, Lirilo, sweet days.
Wait, she's so cute, though.
Wait, can I change?
I kind of want to match her.
One second.
Sorry, I won't be lilac anymore.
It's so similar, actually.
This is kind of funny.
Except her ahog it goes down and mine goes up.
We look like sisters or something.
Wait a second.
This is kind of freaky.
Okay, let's keep playing.
Oh, premium chat, thank you.
Oh, premium chat!
Her voice is so cute.
Today, I was totally pushed by my gen mate, Suzuka Yozora, to play a horror game.
Actually, I didn't look into see if Liruri Tachibana is a real YouTuber or not.
But...
Congrats, man, for your new journey as a YouTuber.
Kind of looks like she's better at pushing her merch.
I'm going to play cursed ruins, re-home.
Just hearing your voice give me energy.
Do you guys feel that way about me too?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I mean...
You guys still think I'm cuter than...
Liruri, right?
Yes?
Yes!
My Oshi saves the world again, Kon Liruri.
I think I told which one is the evil sister.
No!
What do you mean you're not sure?
Oh,
is Klaus?
Do I just need to up my appeal for you guys?
Hell yeah!
I need to up my appeal!
She has whiskers!
I have pointy ears!
I have four ears!
Why would you say that on a collab?
You're right, I'm like bullying.
Shit,
the movement looks so good though, right?
Like, apparently this game has some rumors.
The flylack had caught ears.
They said a lot happened during development and it was almost cancelled.
Die it literally on the line!
We have Tachibana Lirudy at home.
And it's me!
It's not even true, I can't help but wonder.
By the way, do you guys know this game?
Let me know in the comments if you've played it or if it's your first time.
Oh, we're playing?
Oh, I'm reading- I read comments this way.
Wait, we're looking at each other.
Virudy doesn't have shoulder straps.
I can also- I can also up my appeal.
Oh, senior fungus.
Yes, we do in fact think the same way about me.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
And I thank you for Akasupas.
She's totally ignoring them.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.
I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see.
Looks like a lot of you are new to it.
Yooooosh.
So kind of this VTuber live translate for my OG Nihiruri.
Niruri?
You've already given her a nickname!
You've already called her Niruri?
Niruri who?
Yeah!
Tachibana Ludi was a job actress?
Hot dog.
Yeah.
Hearing your voice gives you energy.
Hot dog, thank you.
And D-Rudinki?
D-Rudinki?
D-Rudin will take the lead.
What about- Oh.
It's not like I'm scared or anything.
I might get a little startled though.
By the way, I plan not to get scared.
Oh my gosh, they always donate $2,000.
I love green, Liruri.
Thank you.
Thank you for so much.
Thank you, thank you.
I might scream.
Maybe.
Probably.
Oh,
so be careful with your volume, especially if you're wearing earphones.
Alright then, let's get started right away!
Cursed Ruins!
Rehome!
She may be cute, but Minto is another level?
Oh, the Saikyu or Teruhashi rival shows up.
I heard Dirudin has more voice.
Why suddenly Dirudin?
She looks like she plays through OBS.
This is a horror game where you try to escape from a ruin sealed by a curse.
Oh, Dirudin, I think you need to adjust the volume.
The game is too loud.
It's too loud.
All over the ruin, there are doors that are cursed.
And it seems you have to use Ofuda charms to lift the curses and proceed.
Leave my Yoshi alone.
Doesn't that sound a bit too real?
Lucky,
lucky.
Lirudine.
Curse of Lirudine.
Can you pass this money along to the lady on your right?
Look, you could very easily donate to her.
Just hearing that kind of thing already makes my heart race.
But I'll do my best to escape.
So please everyone, cheer me on, okay?
Oh, I'm playing the game!
Wait, I'm actually the streamer!
Ooh, what is that?
Wait, this is kind of scary.
It's so quiet, it's actually scary.
That's what I just said.
I'm turning it down.
What the heck?
Weird.
Maybe it's just my imagination.
what's their imagination what is this thing they're really controlled oh if you use this it creates an area where enemies can't get close there's enemies in this game what is this starting to feel a bit dizzy wait what is this oh pick up looks like you can see the map while you're holding this ah okay so Q create.
Is this even the right way?
Wait, who's talking?
Me or the streamer?
The vibe here is bad.
I'm scared.
I didn't expect to play this kind of game.
What is this?
Let's check this place out.
Oh, if the enemy spots us, we should run and hide here.
Oh, we can run.
Oh my gosh.
There's stamina.
Wait, this is It's so crazy!
Mito, cute Oshi, no other thoughts in this brain.
Thank you!
Is that not an enemy?
Didn't I just pass here?
Yeah, but like I have to go the other way.
Why?
I'm scared but I have to know!
No you don't, girl!
It was- it was moving at me!
Did you hear that?
What if it kills me?
Let's just go for it.
Okay.
It's not in here anymore?
What is this so lit up though for?
Nothing.
Calm down, Nirudi.
Stay cool.
Yeah, Nirudi.
You're freaking out.
I'm getting nervous.
Me too!
Why am I suddenly in this spooky game?
Oh.
Oh!
There's the, there was the, there was the enemy.
Why is it colder in this room?
I saw it.
I accidentally used my salt.
Wait, will this kill me?
Let's see.
Oh.
Oh, look at her face.
It's behind me.
Wait, where do I hide?
Wait, oh, it's going away.
Uh-oh, wait.
Is the barrier fading?
Uh-oh.
Don't come closer!
Woo!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Surely it'll disappear, right?
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's leaving, it's leaving.
If I die, though, I wonder what happens.
Let's see.
I'm curious what happens.
Yeah, GG, Otsuriruri!
Oh, okay.
So we have to do the game.
Okay, pick up.
Pick up.
Wait, pick up.
Oh, freaky!
We'll just get a head start from it then.
And then we know this lady runs at me!
There's
another one in here!
Let's keep going.
Yeah.
I don't like this room.
Why?
It's a healing room, no?
Okay, there's so many rooms, though.
That, like, have the...
Check.
What am I checking for?
The clothes.
Okay, just...
Okay.
Check, check, check.
What am I checking?
Ah!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, more solid.
Okay, good.
Uh-uh.
We're gaming.
I wonder how long this game is though.
What was the... Oh, we need to find the Ofuda, right?
And then...
What?
Huh?
What is it?
I didn't expect to...
Footsteps are mine.
There are footsteps?
Where?
I didn't expect to play an actual scary game.
This camera view makes me dizzy.
It's funny, though, because I'm, like, playing it, but...
Oh, is this the exit?
Ah!
Oh, I thought that was somebody standing there.
Okay, so we found the exit.
Bad news bears.
Kauai-ya!
10 to 20 minutes?
What, this...
of the game or the whole demo?
It's so funny.
Like, I feel...
Like, I'm playing the game, obviously, but it's, like, in this tiny window.
So it's a little less bad?
I think I need to go...
Over here.
I miss the fish.
I miss fishing.
I wish I was fishing, for real.
wishing i was fishing well we found the exit meantosis yeah this looks like a oh no no no
so let's let us open the sealed door oh okay we just need the one
suddenly going wild.
Those chatters are so funny.
Oh, this is a dead end.
Win, win, win, win, win.
It's the...
The entire demo is 10 to 20.
Cool, cool.
Thank you for checking.
I really appreciate it.
She's getting so many Akasupas.
Dirudy is top VTuber of the world.
I'm sorry, Dirudy.
I did not know your game.
She just wants to save right now.
It's not scary, chat.
Wait, I have the...
Oh, I have it.
Open!
Okay.
Nice.
Is this the end of the game?
What is this?
While you're holding this item, it can block one attack.
Oh my gosh.
Am I gonna get a...
passed away.
She's so calm.
She's so cool.
I can't even speak anymore.
She's so chill.
She's so collected.
Couldn't that be...
Dang it.
Wait, I'm kind of a genius.
I got her in the middle of the door.
I'm kind of a genius.
I got her in the door so I could run.
Wait, she just comes running at me like that?
messed up.
How am I supposed to block that?
How am I supposed to...
She just comes and read it at me.
Second chat is so scared, a bunch of babies.
Her surprise face is too cute.
She says, wait, wait, wait.
Quiet horror is the worst.
Crops to the effect team.
It was so real, I got goosebumps.
They're so funny.
I'm scared, though.
I don't want her running at me.
I'm actually scared of her running at me.
I don't like getting run at, like, you know.
Okay.
I wonder what this is used for.
I could chop her up.
Ah!
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Please don't come down this way.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Wait, this is messed up.
Can I use the...
I
don't think I can clear this game.
Literally gave up.
Quick game.
Yeah, let's call it a day for now.
Well then.
Isn't the screen acting a little weird?
This isn't part of the game, right?
Can you guys still see it properly?
Did it crash?
The stream is down?
Oh no!
Wait.
This isn't her webcam, right?
Looks like it's down maybe.
Let's just restart once.
She's still really cute though.
It won't start.
This is seriously bad.
What should I do?
The stream stops halfway.
My immersion!
Are you telling me that cute woman was a cute woman all along?
Ending without saying anything is probably bad.
No, you don't understand.
It was a... it was a... it was a... it was a... it's not your fault.
I need to report it on social media.
Where did I leave my phone?
Wow!
She's got birch!
Oh, wow.
Oh, she's doxxed.
Looking at it, looking at it like this is a little embarrassing, but it's proof of how hard I worked.
Prism Live, fourth generation.
Oh, cute!
That's an important word to know for your oshi, or for, yeah, for your oshi is totoy.
It's pret means precious.
So dreamy.
Wait, did she get a figure too?
Oh, you're so cute.
This pose and this is so cute.
This pose and expression are just perfect.
Mountain cut design.
Okay, so we got to find our phone.
Wait, did you read a magazine too?
No wonder she was getting Wazoo.
She's so popular.
Wow.
Need to be.
We're not going to get attacked by like a running lady, are we?
Did we leave our phone in the bathroom?
In the toilet?
No?
Wow, this is a nice apartment too.
And, oh, there it is.
Let's let the viewers know.
post it I'm really sorry the stream suddenly stopped earlier my PC showed a blue screen and completely froze it's so frustrating that we couldn't play till the end even though you came to watch but I, D-Duddy will do my best to fix things so please let me try again next time thank you so much to everyone who was worried about me I'll get everything fixed and be back so please be there for my comeback okay she's so cute but it's It was just a... It was just a blue screen.
News at 5.
EMVTuber-Minto.
What did I do?
Reveals famous JP Dirudy.
No!
Dirudy.
Bye!
Okay.
You guys are going to cancel me.
Oh, she scared me in the mirror.
Whoa.
This place is nice.
Who's this guy?
He's my absolute favorite.
Turn off the room lights.
Wait, I want to explore the rest.
You act like this.
Wait.
You act like you wouldn't do this too.
Hey, shut up.
Hey.
We're not talking about me here.
Okay.
Real lights.
Oh, here.
What was that sound?
Was that my...
Wait, we're just gonna leave the computer like this?
But it's...
Okay.
I like how the figure is glowing.
Good night.
No shower.
No change of clothes.
Just like a real VTuber.
October 8th end.
Thanks for sticking with me till the end!
Wait, the overlay is so cute, actually.
Did you all enjoy the demo?
If you liked it, don't forget to add to your wishlist.
The full release is planned for 2025, so wait for it with excitement.
Oh, it's over!
Yuduki Disaster warning system Oh that was the lady that was like Some guy has just died This is so fun though This was This was So like I knew it was like a girl That was a VTuber and some spooky things happened But I didn't expect to play the game In the overlay like that That was so funny funny i was like watching a mirror if you guys also want to know what it feels like to be a vtuber then you can play this it's like i was really watching a vtuber yeah yeah my immersion was so immersed
maybe i should get some cuter overlays maybe maybe that will up my Make sure the collab Maybe that will up my appeal Maybe It was nice for D2D to help out a small VTuber like you, Minto Yeah, she was so sweet
Wow, let me go change buck Oh
I'm changing Don't look Don't look I'm changing I'm changing.
Okay.
Just a peek.
Yay.
So that was Tachibana Rirudy.
What's that?
Hold on.
Let me see what.
Reincarnated.
Yes.
So that was fun.
Okay.
Let's do the next one I have.
The next one.
This one I chose because it just kind of looked interesting i guess i don't know um yeah i'll read the description actually it said like popular user defined tags for this product and it said exploration and i was like i like that i like that i like that so this one is called mumble pines the arrival and it says in this first person story driven horror game you take a job as a janitor to access a rundown island summer camp that got shut down after the disappearance of your brother which was one only one of many incidents it's up to you to uncover the island's buried secrets i chose this one because it looked good it kind of reminded me of like the fire watch game handshake yeah mum mumble mumble pines mumbo no mumbo mumbo am i saying it bad
pines.
No, no Mambo.
So I chose this one because, yeah, like I said, it just looked good.
And I was just kind of interested in him.
Okay, let's try it.
Play.
Mambo number five.
Tag you on TikTok.
Oh, I don't have a TikTok, but thank you.
Um, hold on.
Why?
Is this like...
I think I'm lagging.
The game is humongous.
Give me one second.
Uh...
Then who did he tag?
I don't know.
Is there a mint imposter on TikTok?
Because it's not me.
I don't have a TikTok.
Like I have a personal TikTok.
But...
Jack, welcome back!
Hold on.
The game has been loading and I'm waiting for like a title screen.
Oh, but nothing is...
Oh, oh.
Compiling shader.
Oh my god.
You guys, look at this.
The shaders.
It's compiled.
I've never seen this before.
Oh my gosh.
I'll try.
Okay, maybe once this happens, I'll stop lagging a little.
Minky is the spookiest and what else?
Freakiest?
Thank you!
Bye-bye frame rate.
Frames per sometimes.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, let's see.
Okay, settings.
Settings, please.
We'll do everything we need to.
Oh wait, let me FPS, there we go.
It's another slider.
Is this...
Keep zero for unlimited.
No, no, no.
No camera shake.
I'm so smooth.
Okay.
That should be better.
Much better.
Okay, we're still smooth.
We're still smooth.
Start a new game.
It's been 2.5 years since he went missing.
The police investigated the camp, but didn't, wait, what?
But all I know is they're lying about this place.
So I will find out what happened by myself.
Breaking the answers to those left in the dark.
And find my brother!
It was so fast, the tag!
Hello?
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh.
Whoa, it looks nice.
Game save.
Do you see, like, the camera, like, gets wobbly when I turn my head?
I hope this doesn't get me motion sick.
We're fishing again!
I can't stop fishing!
There goes last ship for the whole month to leave this god-forsaken island.
There's voice acting.
Aw, man.
What's this?
Nothing, just a shovel.
You guys see that, like, head wobble whenever I move them, like, move around, though?
Hey, you must be the new janitor they hired.
I can't greet you in person right now, but I left a videotape in the main lodge.
On there, you find all the information you need to work here.
Okay.
If I need your help at some point, I will call you over the speaker system.
But for now, make yourself at home.
What is the side?
Why do they...
What kind of entrance is this?
Chat and Minky, I have something to admit in front of everyone.
Even if I'm not in membership, I love Minky.
Ah, thank you!
Wait, they're AI voices?
How can you tell?
Wait, how can you tell?
Uh-oh, there's stamina on running, which means there's going to be a reason that we need to run.
Because it's so flat.
Ma.
Damn.
Just arrived and almost got killed already.
Okay.
I think you guys are right.
Damn.
Just arrived and almost got killed already.
Why is it so like...
What does that say?
lodges oh that's a d i thought it was a i was a louges this place doesn't need a janitor it needs a full rehaul like phil thank you so much for the 10 gifted well usually i wouldn't be like i would be more like ah ai voices i probably i won't play but because um Nice to meet you,
by the way.
Well, it's just a demo.
Snake, thank you so much for the time get there.
Yeah, maybe they're placeholders, you know.
Maybe they plan on getting real people for the actual game.
So, we will hope for that.
We will fingers crossed for that.
Can I go?
Oh, I guess I just have to go inside here.
What's in here?
TV, a whole room just for the TV?
I think this place janitor jobs coming soon.
Why does this place need a janitor when it's not even functional?
Does the guy on the loudspeaker even exist?
Oh, here's our TV.
on though it's 20 august 2022 baby i can't go back there
this is such a interesting wait can i read this i don't think i can where is he even broadcasting from hello click click click e click i'm clicking oh camp mumble pines.
Before we can get to the fun part, we have to talk about some rules on this island.
In case of an emergency, please notify the staff immediately.
Am I not?
For your own safety, swimming in the ocean is not allowed.
Our lake, however, is open to use for everyone.
Oh, nice!
On the entire island, it is strictly forbidden to make open fires outside of designated fire locations in the rare case of a forest fire please make your way to the evacuation point and wait for further instructions but for now make yourself at home in your assigned sleeping lodge and feel free to explore our beautiful island oh and one more thing yeah after 9 p.m.
it is strictly forbidden to go outside of the sleeping area due to previous inconveniences with visitors.
It was the static?
Okay.
I guess we got some jobs now then.
Let's just push it open.
After 9 p.m.
I don't have a watch.
Oh, we still don't have any jobs.
Okay, we'll just follow where the game wants us to go.
Wait, so I can go swimming in here?
Ooh, wow.
This is really
Um, I think they're putting artificial dye in the lake, or it's contaminated, or something's wrong here.
You know how, like, they'll put an artificial coloring in some water to make it look more appealing?
Like, a lake should never look this blue.
Yellowstone acid water.
Yeah, exactly.
Go to your sleeping lodge, okay?
My bad!
Remember how I stressed the importance of learning how to swim earlier?
Let's...
Oh.
You're okay, buddy.
You're okay.
You're fine.
This place is humongous, though.
Okay.
You're okay.
Uh-oh.
This place is dangerous and humongous.
Does this not also have a door knob?
I just push it open?
Yep.
Is this other people's stuff?
Oh, checkers.
Tags, exploration.
You're right.
I tried to explore the lake and we saw where that got me.
Okay, I'm pressing, pressing, pressing, pressing, pressing, pressing, E.
Oh, there.
You can hear me.
Head to the west side of the island.
There is an old shed where you need to pick up some things for me.
Okay.
Don't go through the water, though.
You won't make it.
You died.
Hi.
Chad, I joined.
It's late.
What's going on?
We just started our third game.
So...
Okay.
um we are a guy oh i realized your vision like goes blurry i have to go in there that thing looks it looks like it'll collapse any second the uh lack of like wildlife and stuff is kind of freaking me out i don't know oh wow you think i'll die here too yeah we're a janitor for some reason I didn't know that a...
I mean, I guess places need to be cleaned up for sure.
Wait, what's that over there?
My brother never taught me how to swim.
No.
Um...
What was I gonna say?
I didn't realize that like camps needed like a janitor.
The death screen is so abrupt.
It's so funny.
It really is!
Wait, do you think...
You think that guy that's broadcasting is up here?
What if we go up there and it is a skelly man?
And he's been dead the whole time!
Tags exploration?
Mystery solved.
Bro died in 10 inches of water.
So there's this lady on TikTok who every October she does spooky lake month.
And she starts her videos by going, um yes hello and so every time i hear that everybody knows always just like yeah it's spooky lake man it's spooky as she does every day she does a different spooky story about like like spooky like hydrology stuff like some lakes that are just kind of like a little freaky you know and there was one that she talked about the other day that was um it was
there was an active volcano it erupted and created a crater the crater filled up with water and the but the lake was extremely deep it was like super duper deep not like your average like it was it's much deeper than normal for some of some of these lakes and one night um the the volcano was still like you know somewhat active and so um and so it was like constantly releasing like little little gas bubbles you know of like yeah the gas buildup yes yes yes this is the story and it was constantly releasing like this carbon monoxide maybe but um yeah like a suit like just like you know i can't remember what exactly it was but eventually it like there was one night where um it like billowed over all it like yeah essentially let out like this nasty fart and the gas went rolled down the hill basically and there was a village kind of there was a village pretty close and the gas was so fast it was like 40 miles per hour and it rushed through this village which everybody just basically
suffocated to death yeah the co2 and it killed it killed everybody it It killed all the animals.
Like, they, one day, it was just, one day, literally a whole entire village was wiped out because of this one lake in their sleep.
Like, you would never know it was coming because the gas was just so fast.
And everybody was, was asleep.
And the, um, it took, like, several years for, like, they, people went to the village and noticed, like, all the animals dead, all the people dead.
And they were like, what the heck happened?
And it took, it took, you know, scientists and police.
several years before they were like, oh, before they could like investigate and be like, oh, this is this is what happened to this whole what the
whole village?
It's so freaky.
I wonder if there's fall damage.
Okay, we cannot check.
Oh, oh, we're fine.
Okay, anyway.
I just wanted to share that because it was so fascinating.
So interesting and scary oh why do these little tiny tents look like like body they're lined up like body bags or something like a graveyard it's creepy thanks Minto new fear unlocked no just look up that lake and never go to it have you played fire watch I have yes I have I have okay so So we're going into this run-down,
rickety-ass shed, and I might die.
Oh my god, I might die.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Um, what do you need me to grab in here?
She didn't say.
Oh, binoculars.
Bring the equipment to the tower.
The firewatch tower?
The tower.
Which tower?
talking chief tower i guess it has to be that one huh
aren't summer camps supposed to be like you know they're for kids if any kid walks on that
how can you die if you're already dead
okay oh my bad we're about to pass out Okay, hello!
Are you here now?
This guy is a beast running up these stairs.
Oh, yes, here.
Check the radio in the tower.
Uh-huh.
I'm pressing it, I'm clicking it, I'm clicking.
Oh, this radio.
Just kidding.
That seems to be working.
hi oh me again it's starting to get dark so please make your way to your sleeping lodge don't want you to get hurt in your first night
where was home again oh this way it is starting to get dark for a second we're telling the story of a really deep lake that has rapid undercurrents and if you dive more than 15 feet it basically pulls and traps you scary yes yes the co2 lake was lake nios yes that's what it was thank Thank you.
It's so...
Oh, I think I'm hearing the lake.
I thought I heard other footsteps.
Yeah, that was it.
That was it.
Thank you so much for looking it up.
It's dark.
I need a flashlight or something.
I also need a lock on this door and...
Which one's my bed?
Bunk bed?
Honkishu?
Go to your lodge and sleep through the night.
Oh yeah, I am.
Oh, there is a flashlight.
Nice.
Which one's me?
This one?
Sleep?
Oh, okay.
Who's there?
Whoa.
Did Mimi run out of the raid?
It's starting to get spooky.
What is this?
Hmm.
What's this?
Follow me.
I think I've seen this area before.
Hmm.
What's this?
Do I go now?
Oh, it's nighttime.
It says sleep through the night.
Investigate the...
Forbidden area.
Meijmento?
Yeah!
Happy...
Am I...
I don't want to fall into the water.
Don't fall into the water.
We don't know how to swim.
him okay uh probably better to get i don't know where the path is either i'm i'm lost oh here we go we're on the path oh suddenly so spooky ducky thank you so much for the gift thank you thank you they really were body bugs
hmm i think i've seen this place before he's so nonchalant
okay oh so if we had tried before game saved uh oh what's that supposed to mean hello uh hello i follow this thing i follow the rainbow wire oh and i i should have picked up that axe on the tower Oh my god, really?
Okay.
Just use a stick, I don't know.
Are you guys feeling the...
There was another game I almost picked up that like...
It looked the... I couldn't tell what the game was like.
It said it was like a survival horror game.
So I was like, I don't know about this one today.
But the game itself looked very um like old like you know your your your Halloween when you were a child you know that kind of aesthetic where everything was like so decorated and fun weeks of fun weeks of fun nobody's gonna be up here are there where is the guy that should do the trick should do the drink.
That'd be good to have that out in general, no?
Well, I thought I saw something lit up.
What if it's aliens, just like in Firewatch?
Oh, I might have seen the water peeking through.
Why is that axe in the pillow?
I know, right?
When I first saw it, it was like, this is...
I guess no comment about it.
No worries about it.
Is that a spoiler?
What, fire watch?
No.
It's not.
I wish the little marker didn't go away.
This area, I don't like these little tents.
There's something about them that's so freaky.
I can't tell if it's because they look like body bags, like the size of them, or there's just, there's something I might run about them, Tans.
I don't like it.
Alright.
and then once you chop this you're not you're gonna oh that was my own footsteps oh my gosh it scared me bingo okay now you're gonna take it back you're not gonna take it back okay bingo can i go through now oh okay bingo oh my god my god!
Crazy!
Wait, is that a person?
Oh, nope.
What am I doing over here anyway?
I was curious about the thing on the other side of the island, so... You know me, I'm curious.
I'm a curious cat.
Maybe that's why I'm dead.
What's this?
Oh, a generator, or a light?
Okay.
Looks relatively new.
Oh, What's this?
A tape?
Maybe it can give me some clues on what this is all about.
Oh no, is this slender?
Collect all my tapes.
Johnny boy.
I gotta know though, what's the thing on the end of the island?
Tags exploration?
Wait, hmm?
Oh.
Okay.
I thought I was about to die.
Don't go into the water!
You can't swim!
Hatch to nowhere, right?
A little strange.
Am I at the right spot?
Maybe it's over there.
Where am I?
Return the Vod.
Or suffer my curse.
We in slender now.
Did you guys ever play Slender?
Like the original game?
Actually, I was thinking about it the other day.
And I was like, I don't know if I actually ever played Slender.
I might have, but I don't...
Oh, it was a toilet!
I thought so!
Someone's taking the most scenic piss of their life out here.
PewDiePie play it.
I think I watched someone play it many years after.
But I did watch Marvel Hornet.
I don't know.
Maybe I played it but didn't beat it.
I just don't remember.
PewDiePie, he's a grandpa.
He's a grandpa?
Wait, actually?
How old is his kid?
Oh,
he's not.
His son is four at E3.
This kid is four?
Me when I spread misinformation.
I feel like I'm about to get a key and open the TV room.
Well, where do I get the key?
But where would I even play this?
Wait.
The TV room.
Oh, look.
It was locked.
Maybe the key is still in the reception.
Okay, we're going to reception.
But, like, where would I even play this?
This guy is, he was so serious about wanting to find his brother, and now he's like, like, where do I even play this?
Like, where is, oh, there it is.
Are we going to get in trouble?
Fool?
Had a drinking buddy in college who often insisted we co-op slender.
Usually involved me navigating the game and him running out of the room.
Go, Vito!
The ghost in frills.
That's me.
Okay, so we go to reception.
Okay.
I'm running, running, running.
Don't want to pass out, though.
Oh, oh, okay, there's our marker.
Guys, voice acting is flatter than my OC!
Ow, hold on.
Just our dang second.
Oh, this way.
Where is that guy that was over this?
Where does that guy sleep?
Where?
Why is nobody here?
Why does this place need a janitor?
Like, I thought we were going to work...
Like, janitor implies, like, a school or an office building.
Something.
This is just a dang...
Uh...
It's just a run-down park.
Did that door just open itself?
Wait, can we not go in here?
So, wait, is that the...
Watch the tape in the TV room?
One really funny thing about, like, Unity...
Is it has given the ability for anybody to make a beautiful game...
but not everybody has the ability to make a good game you'll get you'll get was it this one oh yeah okay my game saved oh no wait they never came back who will stop using this font please I can't read it whoever left this behind wanted someone to watch it.
Let's see what they were so desperate to show.
Oh my
gosh, it's just like the ring.
Seven days, seven days.
What is happening?
I can't tell.
Noon.
Oh, now we're playing the game in in
Wait, we're playing...
Ooh, we're playing a movie game.
Great, I guess flashlights are overrated anyways.
Oh, that's what that was?
Okay.
Go this way?
Wait, I have to...
Okay, we can't go this way.
Just kidding.
Oh, wait, I forgot I have to push open the doors, right?
This better not become Outlast.
Okay, I don't push open the doors.
These ones actually have handles.
Just kidding.
What is this game about?
I have no idea.
Okay.
Oh.
Beep, beep, beep.
Wait.
Eight.
Zero, zero, eight.
Yeah!
So, wait, is it this one?
It is.
Oh, but I don't have my flashlight.
It's too dark.
Oh yeah.
Welcome.
Just start employing it here.
Since you are
the...
Oh, hours.
You will receive a credit to
your...
Just random person.
And their brains!
This is not what monitors should look like.
What am I doing?
Find the code to open the door.
Okay, I feel like I'm gonna get chased in here.
I'm gonna find the code and then something's gonna run at me.
Oh.
red over there.
Yeah, they just put their family...
Oh, wait!
Seven.
Oh, seven!
Wait, did the other one have one?
No.
Why is there red sometimes?
You guys see that, right?
What's this game called?
Mumble Pines.
Oh!
Is it a...
I can't tell, I'm scared.
Turn off the flashlight.
I didn't realize it was on because before it was off, right?
Oh, I think it's just...
Oh, it's electricity.
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
So, seven...
Uh...
Okay.
Wow.
Or...
Seven...
Maybe I have to turn it off for some of the other paintings or pictures as well.
Oh wait!
One?
I can't... I guess not.
Never mind.
You just have to find them.
Eight?
Aw, the bear.
Seven, one, eight.
emergency broadcast system wait employees to fire teddy bear on desk no private stuff allowed Rachel the one with these stupid sunglasses grow up you're literally in a bunker the smoker I swear if someone's gonna light this place on fire it's gonna be me not some moron with a cigarette so you for the alcoholic like that puked on my seat twice this week.
I don't care if he knows my boss.
What?
Why did you write that down?
Oh, three!
Seven, one, eight, three.
But how am I supposed to know the order?
Oh, wait!
The order is this.
So teddy bear.
Teddy bear glasses.
So three.
Dang it.
Okay.
I have to go find them again.
So, eight three.
Eight three.
Eight three seven one.
Oh my gosh.
Scary.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Oh, over here.
Nope.
Just kidding.
Well, as soon as I'm right here, I guess I can check.
The alcoholic is the last one, so...
Yeah, 8371.
Eh?
Stinking maze.
Haskaido for making this such a cozy horror street boss.
Wait, where did my dummy friend go?
Oh, da-da!
Your dummy friend.
8, wait, 8, wait, 8, 3, 7, 1.
Ding-ba!
Also, thank you so much, Miro!
Glad you're liking it.
Let's see what this door is hiding.
Uh...
I didn't, I didn't learn literally anything about the game.
game from this demo.
I don't know anything is going on.
I hate to say it, but full playthrough win.
Okay.
All right.
I have one last game demo that I downloaded, which maybe you guys have heard of this series.
So similar to how I started with Achilla's art game, with another game that is a little well-known in that game we'll just load it up now oh hold on let me capture it
uh Why isn't it capturing?
Ah!
I'm on observation duty!
Hey!
I'll need your guys' eyes to find some anomalies!
So I guess there's an eighth one coming out!
And from the screenshots, there was an observation duty game where you were able to walk around.
and find the anomalies and I guess that this one is also that style right behind me it says navigate so I know right there's eight of these games
so yeah started with chill as art and ending with observation duty let's check it out oh whoa attention employee anomalies have been previously cited in the monitored area Pay extremely close attention to the surveillance camera footage.
File an anomaly a report, ASAP, when you notice something has changed.
I'll need your guys' help, okay?
There's a purple anomaly in the bottom right now!
Oh, wait, maybe I can't walk around then.
Okay, let's look.
We're at a yard?
Oh, keep...
Oh, it's a lighthouse!
Oh, it's kind of freaky.
Okay.
Whoa.
Purple.
Okay.
Well, what am I supposed to...
Okay, so far.
Everything seems fine.
All right, guys.
It's the anticipation of like moving to the next camera that freaks me out a little bit, you know?
It is really detailed.
Like, this?
This part looks great.
Oh, oops, not bad.
Basement.
They got a rat problem.
This is so chill.
Why is she orple?
Because I'm getting into the Halloween spirit.
I am the spirit.
I'm also really bad at these games, you guys.
So, this is why I don't really play.
Anomaly type games because I'm terrible at them.
There's going to be a body in that bed.
Probably.
This would be a fun collab game.
I was thinking that too.
It's always nice to have an extra...
Oh, there's teeth!
It's always nice to have an extra pair of eyes on these types of things, you know?
I'm really bad at like memorizing everything.
So...
Was this moving before?
I feel like it probably was.
See, I'm so unobservant.
I imagined it was because it controls this.
Wait, but how...
Before there was a light.
Oh, maybe it was the shadow passing by.
You know, they're always just like, count the number of bottles, count the colors, count everything.
present and future oh we're underwater um whoa uh how do i describe this um uh oh here we go uh water anomaly probably in the yard so left click has you click on certain things and right click has you do the entire area.
Good to know.
That one was kind of neat.
I'll take I'm in Observation Duty.
Wait.
I'm on Observation Duty is the paranormal activity of horror games at this point.
Unique and fun at first but a dozen mid sequels.
Oh, was it?
Oh, wait.
I don't think this was here before.
X drop.
Maybe?
I think, you know, they concept of like the anomaly game um wait what's this was this here before always i'm not sure i don't know i think these games can definitely be hit or miss especially if like nothing happens in the game which tends to happen quite a bit that's also another reason i don't play them very often but i still think they're fine i think they're a nice game for sure yeah the graphics are getting this one looks really good i hope that we get to play not just this one what time do we go until
spooky cozy yeah there's a genre i definitely think that's a there's a there's a place for spooky cozy you know
but you know now we have so many anomaly type games where it's like exit a is one of them that got a whole movie like they definitely popularized the the concept was the rat trap always in the interior these ones yeah sorry
it's brighter what's brighter here in here you think it's brighter in here than before
try oh interior not basement oh oh this i don't know i don't know it's a great question
i wonder if we'll get anything crazy i wonder if it's like more scripted because it's demo you know definitely interested new lamp where ah this changed uh object replacement probably
what no it was a different type no this was definitely missing it was a different type of cross object movement okay yeah I had a circle top it did it did yeah let's try another one I don't want to get in trouble though Missing object?
I tried object replacement, it didn't work.
Oh, it is that type of cross.
It was missing the floaty.
Oh, I see.
I observe a cute ghost in the corner.
Oh,
spooky.
Object movement?
Freaky.
Image anomaly?
Yeah, let's try that.
That sounds like it could be right.
Okay.
Good job, team.
Sometimes they're so obvious.
Obviously, like, the obvious ones like that I can get.
The cross one, I had been looking at it every time.
So, I was like, Hmm.
Hmm.
I think I'll get that one.
But...
So far so good.
Yeah, maybe.
I think.
Maybe.
Hmm.
I need to start looking in here.
I've been only looking on the outside.
I feel like something's going to happen with this thing here.
Whirlpool.
Ah, yeah!
Oh, we have an abyss in the basement.
And it's screaming.
What?
Uh, we have...
Uh...
We have a hole.
Oh, it's a hole.
We have a hole in the basement.
Okay, I'll fix.
They're so efficient.
I wonder how long this demo will be.
Okay.
So far, the game looks really good, though.
I wonder if we'll get, like, an anomaly on each map.
Well, I guess maybe we...
Actually, we probably just played the night on only this map, I imagine.
I don't know.
Oh,
that's the wind, I think.
I thought I heard something.
Hmm.
Yeah, it's like Phenaf where it ends at six.
Yeah.
Yeah, you guys are right.
There's like a little symbol down here.
You see that?
It seems kind of like...
creepy.
Hey!
Christ Jesus.
Every time!
Every time.
Man.
Okay.
Ugh.
Well, we're not getting in trouble yet, though.
So that's a... that's a plus?
That's good.
Uh, orpoh.
Not sure.
I'm looking.
Window.
What window?
Is this map a reference to a movie?
I don't know.
Not sure, actually.
I thought this was a person for a second.
Spook me.
Missing handrail on the stairwell.
Is there?
These windows?
Is there something?
I don't see anything.
Could you guys ever live in a lighthouse?
Could you guys ever be a lighthouse keeper?
I don't think I could.
Like, I've thought about Firewatch maybe, but also, then I, you know, I've watched a lot of videos that kind of romanticize the Firewatch occupation.
I watched one, I watched one single Firewatch video that was like, here is the realistic, here is the real, like, facts.
This is like real, realness about Firewatch, being a Firewatch person.
And I was like, I was like, okay, never mind, I changed my mind.
I don't actually mind probably being alone.
I think actually That's the part that...
Eee!
Um...
Uh...
Rope Anomaly!
Wee!
Creepy, creepy, creepy, creepy crawlies!
Oh, it's funny.
Um, but yeah.
I don't know.
Anomaly.
Ghost in bottom right corner?
No!
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
Ah!
Change color.
Object replacement.
Probably.
Not Orpal!
On this specific rope anomaly.
I guess because they're like...
How else would you describe it, huh?
They add an extra option for us.
Hmm.
Okay.
But yeah, I think probably Lighthouse Keeper is maybe a little similar to Firewatch.
But the thing about Firewatch was like, maybe I could do Lighthouse.
But also, Lighthouse creeped me out so much.
About Firewatch though, they were like, yeah, you can't really bathe.
And I was like, no!
Change color, it's lilac now.
Lighthouses seem more homey?
See, not at night though.
They creep me out, I think.
There's too many horror games and stuff that take place in a lighthouse.
And I've heard too many freaky stories.
Lighthouse Willem DeFoe.
I haven't watched that movie.
Isn't Robert Pattinson in it too?
I'm sure you've seen the movie.
I haven't, I haven't.
I just know about it, but I haven't seen it.
I wonder if we'll get something really freaky.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Oh, no, guys!
Uh-oh, we're in trouble!
Multiple active anomalies?
What?
What am I missing?
Eh!
The lamp differed in Lighthouse and Keeper's...
This one?
No!
I need
more obvious anomalies I'm stupid please I don't know I have no idea but stairwell handrail left of pillar what is it missing needs more yellow paint ah thank you thank you thank you the light in the building on the dock was off when you started Oh, I see.
Okay, let's go to there.
Are you sure?
Dead body.
I don't know.
I feel like, well, maybe light anomaly in the pier.
Let's try it.
No.
Maybe not.
Unless I'm doing the wrong thing.
I thought it was on, though.
We have an abyss problem, everybody, in the keeper's cabin.
Um, we have an abyss problem.
Can I get...
There's a barrel on the top of the hill in the yard.
It was not there before.
This one?
Extra object?
Or this one?
I'll try both.
No?
This one.
Extra object.
Nice!
Catch!
You guys have such good eyes.
Nice catch!
It's always harder for me, too, because I'm less focused on the game and totally more focused on you guys, like, reading chat.
Wait.
Were these here before, or am I crazy?
Yes, this was here before, right?
The lantern is off.
This?
I think it was always off, or maybe it wasn't.
She's obsessed with us!
Maybe a little.
Maybe we're okay now though, we got a couple.
Was this mug always here?
I'm gonna try.
Ah!
I did that!
Okay!
Good job team, good job!
that fine to you, the viewer.
It always feels good when you find something like that, you know?
Where you're like, I think my intuition is saying something.
To me, to you!
Me?
To me.
I want a big freaky one.
Give me a big freaky anomaly.
Give me the big man.
Bigger man.
Extra bottle.
Where are we at?
Like, even the shadows from, like, the fireplace.
Like, moving around, flickering like that.
I don't know.
I'm, you know, I'm not a game designer.
I don't know how easy or difficult things are nowadays with like getting assets and stuff from the stores, but it's just it's like a little detail like that that I like.
The extra mousetrap is concealed by the crates.
This one?
This one has always been here.
Is this an extra one?
The left one.
This one?
This one's always been here though.
I swear there's an extra mousetrap in the basement.
No, there's always been this.
I've always noticed these three.
Actually, this one I haven't noticed before because it was so dark.
Oh.
My bad.
It's okay.
Ah!
Sorry.
No worries at all.
Look at the fourth one.
I did.
I did try this one.
Let's keep going, though.
I don't want to stay in one spot for too long, you know?
Just in case.
Ah!
Is there a person?
Um, uh, intruder.
The window.
Creepy!
Oh,
what if we had gone in here?
Well, they were in the window.
Ah!
Intruder!
This is not... this is an extra object, right?
Oh my gosh!
That got me good!
Holy cow!
Ah!
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, I asked for something freaky, you guys.
I think I got it.
anxiety why was it so slow maybe that was pop-up was because he was in the place oh my god
wait this is this is different right room manipulation oh my gosh that was so freaky
Holy cow.
I asked for something freaky, man.
Wait, was this always flammable?
Object replacement, maybe?
Was that our Uber Eats delivery guy?
I guess not.
I was about to head to bed now, I'm not so sure.
I'm sorry!
Sorry, guys.
That was me.
You need to quit being so freaky now, okay?
Were these boxes always so green?
That was spooky.
Don't scare us like that.
I'm sorry for screaming.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry for screaming like that.
Freaky.
Freaky, freaky.
I screamed too.
The flash, like the jump scare.
Okay.
I guess they do that to be like, hey, this guy is in the location.
Like he's somewhere on the camera somewhere.
You have to find them.
But I thought it was related to the guy in the window.
Oh, we got a bird.
Wait, my head is kind of blocking him, though.
Let me move down.
Just a tad, actually.
I'll move like here.
There you go.
We got a bug!
Look at him!
He's kind of wiggly.
Oh!
Local enough.
Oh, here!
Oh, this is cool!
Wait, three!
Oh!
Wait, this is cool!
Wait, but where's the fourth one?
I got...
Three out of four!
Oh, here he is.
Oh, cool!
Way!
I like that!
That was fun!
That's a fun little addition.
I liked that a lot.
You find like the anomalies in the one localized area, multiple of them, and...
Yeah, I liked that.
MGS 2- I know how I was thinking it too.
I was like, oh no, the Seagulls.
cake what are you even saying right now you killed birds that's why you're the best big bird got
the biggest man you guys see him in the fog
um intruder wait select all faces looking upwards no way i have to do a right now?
We got the biggest man!
Oh, my huge guy!
Hugeest guy!
Wait, that was so cool!
We'd like a Titan for real coming in.
Oh, I was gonna say why is there music?
I think it's because we're in the final hour.
Very cool.
Is it quiet?
Can you guys hear it?
There is a body in the bed?
No, I think that's just it ruffled up.
No, it's kind of hard to see.
It's a little dark.
Was the basket always open?
What basket?
In what room?
Hmm.
Ah!
Oh, we were so close!
Object movement and basement, missing objects and interior, object replacement and pier.
We were so stinking close.
Only three!
Dang it, literally in the last hour!
Object movement in basement.
Maybe it was one of the mouse traps.
Let's try again.
Let's go to the...
No.
This!
I told you it wasn't flammable.
I tried.
I didn't know what it... Okay.
Okay, okay.
Now we know, though, kind of...
How things are like here.
We can check...
And it said something in this room, too, no?
or the basket is open.
Okay, the basket is open.
Run it back.
Okay.
I feel like I have a pretty good handle on things now.
Maybe.
I'll still need your help, please.
Maybe it was an image anomaly technically.
Oh, maybe, maybe, maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
Extra bottle on the pier.
Was there or is it just these two here?
I didn't see where an extra one even was.
Ah.
Anomalies start from 15.
Thank you.
That's actually so helpful.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Anomalies coming in.
Coming in high.
Anomalies coming in hot was this always open yes i think it was okay all right coming at you i guess we can also see if like um what's it called if it's scripted or not or if it's random you know if it's scripted for the demo probably not i think was that thing always hanging at the top of the lighthouse uh yes it was
this thing right here yeah i've been keeping my eye on it because i'm like when is it gonna change to like a dead body or something you know scary
if it's not randomized i don't think i'll i think i'll
smoke okay it's not randomized at all i was gonna say if it's not randomized or it is randomized if it's not randomized i was gonna say maybe we won't replay it and maybe we'll just play the full game when it comes out but it's definitely randomized that was that was a quick catch i think
cool that means we'll get some new stuff very cool very cool Something feels different here, and I don't know what.
What is this game?
It's I'm on Observation Duty 8.
But there's no...
Sorry, I thought I heard the hugest of my own.
There's no, like, super story for it, so you can just play it any game.
Was this wheelbarrow always here?
Maybe I never noticed it was a wheelbarrow.
It
was okay.
Things be changing.
We gotta look around.
We gotta find them.
Missing box and stairwell, top left.
This one?
Missing object?
Or here?
Or this would be top left.
No?
Basically a creepy spot the difference game.
Pretty fun with friends around stream.
Yeah, exactly.
Intruder bottom right.
Why am I not finding anything?
Oh gosh.
This is pretty bad.
I feel like we're going to get a warning soon.
Usually they have like two subtle anomalies and then one obvious one.
Ah!
This one.
Uh.
Extra object.
There we go.
Purple.
Hmm.
I'm an invisible man.
Sleep it in your bed.
Okay.
One of the barrels too small in the basement.
I guess we'll check when we go back there.
I thought I heard something talking.
Creepy.
It's also the fact that this game is so quiet, you know.
Oh, extra object.
I know this one.
I look for it now.
Ha ha ha.
this one maybe I can try object replacement
let's see no hmm I guess it was always that so I's oh no well thank you so much for that Tony thank you thank you so so much I really appreciate it this is the series that has some dude that was pooping on the train There's like some really There's like a Some of the games got like kind of raunchy Like I think there had to be like a streamer mode to censor some stuff And then I think once the games really popped off with streamers Then he was like Okay maybe I shouldn't put this stuff in the game Like there was
Handprint There was
That's freaky.
Is he gonna be crawling around now here?
Scary.
Spooky scary.
Spooky spooky.
Oh my gosh, I've been such a Halloween mood now.
Hmm.
Okay.
PT from Death Stranding.
Exactly.
Also feel free to shout out if you see anything or even if you think you see something.
We will try.
It's a photo on the wall different.
In the bedroom, I don't think it was, but I can check.
When we get back there.
I see a ghost.
Yeah!
This one?
No, this has been the same the whole time.
Under the bed, this has been here the whole time.
in there.
Yes, yes, indeed.
Okay.
I gotta start scrolling through these a little bit more quickly, just in case.
We get the warning.
I think you get the one warning, and then if you get the warning again, it's over!
Lantern changed an interior.
Did it?
Interior.
This one?
Why is like flickering kind of you see that uh object movement did it move i think it moved i think it was here before no i'm dealing with some rough stuff but it's been nice to tune in your streams relax man i love your streams with nimmy and bb do oh lunar i hope everything's okay but thank you so much for the super chat i'm glad that i can help a little bit even thank you
okay Hmm.
Mm-hmm.
Uh.
Huh.
Okay, maybe we're doing all right.
Seconds before disaster.
Seconds before we get the beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, you know?
Or the stairwell stair is always red.
They look like super slanted.
My head's kind of blocking it.
They look a little weird, but...
I believe they were.
Sorry.
Oh, it's only two?
Okay.
I think there's an extra board on the shed at the pier.
Extra board in the shed?
Oh, like up here?
I thought there was always two.
Freaky anomaly in bottom left?
I'm watching the stream.
Dream in the mirror?
Oh!
We are once again in the water.
In the yard.
No, that's normal.
The ones on the roof?
Yeah, I think so.
I think so.
I think the two boards on the roof are normal.
I agree.
At least they've always been there.
They're my comfort boards.
Or something.
I don't know.
under the sea under the sea darling it's better downwards when I take it from me I don't want this one I don't want that guy again that scares me
it does look like a body hold on dead body I'm just gonna try I'm just gonna try
Okay, no.
I thought I heard a sound.
That's the thing, again, about this game.
It's not like a scary game, but like the very subtle audio clues and like...
Like just how everything is so like...
It can be so subtle and then you lose your...
You lose your guard and then things jump in your face.
Ah, what is that?
Uh Seam Smoke fog No What is extra object?
Light anomaly?
Yeah, it's a flare Okay, good
Okay, cool I like that we're getting some new ones though It looks weird, doesn't it?
it?
I don't know.
It looks different.
The bed.
The bed looks different to me and I don't know why.
Is it just me?
It always looked like that.
Did it?
I guess I've like gaslit myself into thinking it looks different.
Oh!
Water.
Anomaly in the basement.
That's not good.
Oh no.
It's starting to flood for real.
Uh oh.
We're gonna drown okay everything's fine it's so funny how like things will be like going going crazy like oh my god and then suddenly it's like i'll fixed okay
it's almost three i think that's when we got our first like when it turned three before Bird?
I see no bird.
Cuteness anomaly, top right?
Oh my gosh.
Also, sometimes the anomalies can even be like changing the name, even without that freaky guy around.
Now, the keeper's room always been this cracked.
I think so.
I think I've definitely taken note of.
some of it before I don't know to this extent but I think so they had missing cameras in Oregon yeah missing cameras always freaks me out because I'm just like so focused on going to the next camera the next camera the next camera I never like perceive that one is missing or something it's yeah yeah yeah yeah that one would get me too
Hmm.
Different floor wall textures are brutal.
I know!
Usually floor is very easy to tell.
Oh, that's a...
Okay, it's a worm.
Oh, my God.
Um, is that an intruder?
That is a worm, right?
I think that's a worm.
That's a worm, right?
Uh, intruder?
Yes.
Wait.
Intruder.
It is over.
Missing object in the pier.
What was missing?
Did he die in this game?
Dang.
We got pretty far, though.
It was not a worm.
It was a...
Wait.
So was it that guy's...
Finger?
Should we try it one more time?
I wonder...
Now I'm wondering, is it possible to be the...
What was missing on the pier?
I'm looking around and everything that I see here I saw before as well.
Dutchie, oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gift.
That
was one big finger.
Well, it was also a big guy.
A big baby, maybe.
What was missing here?
I have no clue.
Baby, let me...
I'm going to move my head over just a tad.
Well, I don't know.
It's really hard.
Actually, you know what I'll do instead?
I'll shrink the game.
I'll shrink the game so that you guys can see better.
Because there's some things.
Like probably this here, you never even noticed.
He became a worm for you, girl.
Okay, all right.
This time, this time, this time, this time, this time.
So we got hugest man, and we got his son.
Ah, I didn't even notice the fireplace.
Oh, yeah, that's been there the whole time.
Okay, it's 15 past.
Anomalies will start appearing.
Now.
They will start appearing.
Right now.
There's an anomaly.
Now.
It's right now.
Are you winning, Mintho?
I'm not sure.
I don't know, actually.
I don't know.
I just want to beat the demo.
This will be the last attempt, though.
And if I don't beat it, maybe we'll have a revengeance when the actual game comes out.
we were so close on our first run I'm so ah I'm so ah well I'm glad we got to play the second time we got to see some cool new anomalies in the actual game does it go through multiple locations it does yeah in the actual game there's a lot of different locations I thought it said was to so I feel like to move is what it said i think there's going to be like an element of walking around so maybe they plan on including some more like um when you're not doing the observation part there's a little bit more lore and walking around and exploration like i think that would be really cool something kind of that the game the games i feel like at this point like you do the first couple okay like Like,
you aren't sure of how the success of the game is going to go and stuff like that.
You know, you just kind of put it out there and see if it catches.
But now that we're on Observation Duty 8, I would like some more lore.
Check the teeth?
Eyeballs!
Sorry, I'm totally not even object replacement.
Camera malfunction.
Wait, where?
Which camera?
What are we missing?
Oh, what are we missing?
Crocodile alligator.
I drive a Chevrolet movie theater.
Which one are we missing?
Basement.
Okay, this is what I meant.
Oh my gosh.
No, please God.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
He's gonna show me his finger.
Um.
Yeah.
Goodness gracious, everybody.
Okay, what was I saying though?
I don't remember anymore, but that's okay.
We're focused.
I was just chit-chatting.
I was just speaking my mind, not even paying attention.
Barrel.
Barrel is down.
Oh, is this standing up?
Object movement?
Maybe?
Oh, thank you guys.
I'm really not paying attention at all right now.
okay we gotta we gotta lock in good catch everybody thank you so much for the help good job good job I pat your head too pat pat pat pat pat pat
that's also why I like playing this game on stream though because I feel like it's a little more interactive where you guys get to kind of watch and be on the lookout as well so it feels a little more like we're playing together did the screen get smaller yeah i made it smaller so that i wasn't blocking some of it because i have a big head i think this was image anomaly
is that a cross at the back of the pier it is and it's been there the whole time if it becomes a normal cross without the without the floaty then we have a problem that's our anomaly i should be counting like the number of sandbags one two three four five six seven okay seven i mean i could we could be missing one who knows the camera's shrinking bro camera malfunction
sorry I thought something was weird with the fire okay okay wait did I say 6-7 why did I say it wait why did I say it though oh
because I was counting the bags you guys oh smoke Smoke Worst meme That's so stupid It's actually just so dumb That's okay Let people be dumb Hmm Uh If you just let people do whatever and you just kind of you know just you know just be like i don't care as long as you're not killing anybody then it's you live a happier life i would know i'm dead don't waste your life being upset all the time yeah it'll die out of it memes nowadays like go like crazy you know
extra object in the side of the pier this this has always been here but my head was blocking it before so you might just not recognize it but yeah memes go so fast nowadays you don't like the time it takes to run the joke into the ground is like a millisecond extra barrel in the yard
This?
This has always been there.
It's okay.
Is this an extra box?
Or was it always stacked?
I can't remember.
Okay, never mind.
I think I just didn't realize it was...
I thought it was a big box and I didn't realize it was a stacked box.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, alright.
But we're still seeing new stuff again.
That's always fun.
Every time.
Every single time.
The cross is gone?
No, it's here.
Wait.
Is it longer?
The pier?
room manipulation maybe
ah yeah it got further away oh good catch good catch I just saw that it was there and I didn't recognize to me that it was like pushed back whoa wait oh never mind
good job team I love that word team i love that we can all work together with this you know how is it only two i know the game is quite slow not gonna lie that's why this will be my last time attempting
hmm i want the ropes again they were funny i liked that one or the birds
Oh yeah, this game is like crazy slow burn.
It's very like...
I wouldn't even explain it as atmospheric.
It's atmospheric, but it's a slow atmosphere.
Like...
It's just...
Yeah.
Relys on tension a lot.
Yeah, right, right.
Very much so.
Eee!
Oh,
he's freaky.
Oh, he's really creepy looking.
Eee!
Oh,
I liked how the little, like, anomaly marker jumped up with him.
That was freaky!
That was freaky, freaky.
wow we're still getting so many new ones crazy
that one really freaked me the way he like kind of peeked up
especially for a demo yeah our third playthrough and like we've gotten so many new things only like a couple of repeats but Honestly, mostly new stuff.
Watching on my phone, couldn't see the guy.
Oh, no!
You know what?
Maybe it's for the best.
He was kind of...
He was pretty scary.
I was like, the ropes coming down reminded me of something.
Of course, it reminded me of half-life.
Yeah, of course, of course.
Go back?
To this one?
Missing trap in the basement?
Let's see.
We have one, two, three, four.
Nope.
All still there.
Nice to check though.
The trauma.
Yeah, the trauma of the ropes.
What are those guys called?
In the...
In the game.
Barnacles.
No, no, no, no, no!
Uh-oh, guys.
Uh-oh, do you notice anything?
Oh, I noticed something.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
The water, the water.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I don't think any of the mouse traps moved I don't know Gotta be missing her extra objects Yeah, those are the toughest ones for real
I don't know though
Map interior This one?
No, I think it's still the same Frosted window?
I saw that, and I wondered if they were supposed to be.
They're not!
The frosted glass!
I saw that earlier, too!
Oh, wow.
That's subtle.
That's really subtle.
Oh, my gosh.
Because it's like, I knew they weren't seethrew, but I didn't think they looked the same.
You think the map did change?
I'll try Image Anomaly.
The map is different.
What's different?
Oh, there was an extra!
An extra continent!
Oh, I just thought it was there for...
I don't know, so it's like...
This takes place in a...
Oh, here we go.
This again.
This takes place in a...
I'm going to try object movement.
Different, not America, sorry, different timeline of the world.
Okay, so that's object movement for some reason.
Oh, maybe it was turned around.
That's why it was movement.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, it rotated.
Yes,
yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, so we've taken out a couple.
All right, all right.
Good, good, good.
team good job team
but if we get another warning it won't be another warning it will just be it'll be our last
sparkles in the stairwell I think that's this also this room also has it I think it's just
come on Vita we're at the time of the impsy haunted house we trade you for this Oh, I spy.
I was like, if, if, I spy.
The I spy haunted house.
Holy.
Did we just skip the pier?
We'll see in a second.
I suppose.
I wish we would get more of...
Nope, here's the pier.
I wish we would get more of ones that I've gotten before already, no.
Gosh, that guy was so scary.
Wait a second.
Is it getting brighter?
Oh.
Oh, that's normal, I suppose.
Oh, I guess it's like this...
When the big light rotates.
Okay, okay.
It's the light from the lighthouse.
Still good to check.
Still okay to check.
Yeah.
That is a neat detail, yeah.
I don't know.
I really like the...
the way this game looks.
Why do these, do these look different?
Object replacement?
Missing railing?
Thank you guys!
Nope.
Thank you, thank you.
I've been looking at that one every time and the one time I don't look.
Movement maybe?
These?
Let me try.
Object movement?
They look different, though, no?
Well, guess not.
I think I'm gaslighting myself.
You really start to get to that point of the game where you're just like, this, this was, I like this!
And it was the whole time, literally, from the very beginning.
You're like, there's no way!
There's no way!
Oh, I clicked replacement again.
I thought I did movement.
Was the yellow thing on the pier on the...
Right.
Wait, we are missing something, right?
What am...
Object movement?
Or missing?
Object.
Missing object.
There we go.
Replacement.
Extra?
Extra object.
Extra, extra.
I was going to say, it's definitely different.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you, guys.
Good catch.
Oh.
All right.
There's probably some new ones that appeared while I was fighting with that.
So keep your eyes peeled.
Keep your eyes peeled.
Unless it's a really obvious thing.
I wish I could live in a creepy lighthouse, really?
Ah!
Extra object.
Oh, that one's kind of nice.
They give you, like, a little visual, like, clue because it's sparkling a little bit more.
That one's nice.
The game isn't always so cruel.
Okay.
Let's see.
I bet that baby from before is probably, like, you get an achievement if you die by it, you know?
Die by the giant baby.
Oh my god!
That one gave me chills!
Wait, I have to sleep tonight!
Maybe...
Oh, we have some abyss in the pier.
Maybe I shouldn't have closed with this game!
This is so scary!
Oh my gosh!
I can't believe we're still...
I guess probably I imagine this level is complete.
Or something.
Because there's so many.
There's so many new anomalies that we've gotten.
Oh, scary!
So scary.
It's almost 5, though.
Just go fishing again.
Yeah.
Holy moly.
Windows or Fry's did extra body.
Demon woman.
I had a feeling once we...
Once we...
I thought she would move before...
Like, what?
Like, when I was reporting it, but I didn't think that afterwards she was going to...
Oh, we have another hole.
I feel like they bumped up the scariness.
I feel like that too!
Oh.
Jeez.
Was the mirror on the dresser in interior?
We shall see.
In interior.
Mirror on the dresser.
Was there one?
I don't think so.
The bottles on the pier seem to have moved.
Have they?
I'll try.
There was one.
Oh.
There was one here?
Wait, where at?
Extra rail on the wall and interior.
Um, I don't know.
These have always been here.
Oh, this is a mirror!
Oh!
Wait, it is?
If it is...
Well, you can't just keep sitting on the same screen for so long, though.
If it is, I think I'm silly.
Can't tell.
Or a window.
Yeah, I've noticed that.
I didn't...
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, we might get that spooky guy again, too.
Hey, I don't like him.
I don't like him.
The drawer in the bedroom.
What about it?
I guess we didn't get anxiety, guy.
I guess that was unrelated.
In the last hour, there is music.
There are, I guess, ambiance.
Yeah.
Missing interior map.
No?
still there?
Puddle it?
This?
Is this new?
Uh, extra... Or maybe... Water?
No.
Extra object?
I'm not sure, guys.
I'm not sure.
The puddle was always there.
Okay, I thought so, but some people were... Ah!
We're missing a camera!
Camera malfunction!
Uh, the pier!
Okay.
Alright, she's back.
Let's hope...
Let's pray for some really obvious ones.
Uh...
In front of map?
There's something missing?
This?
Let's see?
Ah, thank you!
Okay, I And I thought it looked a little naked.
Okay.
Oh, the Seagulls!
And Big Bird!
Here we go.
I like that one.
It's funny.
It's cute.
Okay.
All right.
Good job, team.
Hmm.
We didn't get so much in this room, actually.
Ah.
Okay.
Lock in, everybody.
Yeah, lock in.
Stare well.
Wait, the ropes?
What about?
Ah, thank you!
Okay, good job, guys, good job, good job.
Good job, good job.
I'm barking like a dog.
We're so close.
Our shift is almost over!
Four more minutes!
Please!
Oil missing in the lighthouse left of pillar.
Wait?
I think that's the countdown.
Red can at lantern.
Where?
It's okay, we made it anyway!
Holy
is crazy!
Yippee!
Yeah!
Oh good, we were able to complete all of the games.
I'm so happy.
This one I feel like they upped it.
24 is a lot.
I feel like this game you can...
What's the word?
You can kind of get away with only having just a few or something, you know what I mean?
So, yeah, that was a great demo, I feel, of the new one.
Hold on, one second.
One second, one second.
Let's put on some comfy music.
.
Comfy.
Good job, team.
Well, I hope you guys like that little dose of spookiness.
We got a good variety, I feel, of like goofy to silly to actual spooky.
I feel like it was a good mix.
It was fun?
Yeah.
You're awesome.
Thank you, Tri-Princess.
Mr. Jingles, thank you.
Thanks for putting up with our backseat.
No, no, this is the game to backseat, for real.
I love Observation Duty and So Cool to play with Minky and Chat.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, the Dead Lady and the Anxiety guy and the guy climbing.
Oh, my gosh.
There were so many things.
It was so freaky.
Maybe.
Since...
What's it called?
Oh, sorry.
That's the trailer for one of the games.
Since Next Fest is still happening until the 20th.
Maybe I'll pick up a couple more spooky games and that stop stop stop and then maybe we can do another like Red like horror game special.
It was really fun.
I'll be a stream the chillest fishing game when it comes out Yeah, I want to I want to thanks for the fun spooky stream.
Thank you And maybe if not demos maybe I'll do some actual like indie horror games that Yeah Pink closest to poor poop poor poop love the hat yeah I wanted to be hold on I wanted to be in the season I wanted to be spooky um for my schedule this week I have one day that I'm trying to figure out something to do but um uh it's just I should hopefully have it out tomorrow.
Takizo, thank you so much for the podcast, thank you!
Thank you!
So, um...
Yeah, just trying to figure out something to do for Thursday.
Trying to wonder, I'm trying to decide if I should like, do a...
Like, start a new series.
I was thinking maybe Alan Wake.
I almost put... I almost did that today, actually.
Any stream tomorrow?
Yes, I have a collab tomorrow.
Mimi!
Mimi rated us earlier, and Camilla, so we're playing Peek.
Is the first Alan Wake scary?
Because I need to start adding some more games that, like, I can beat.
So I can add to my... I still need... Let's see, hold on.
How many more games do I need?
20?
20 more games that I need to beat before the end of the year.
Alan Wake is tense, not scary.
It can get creepy, but not scary.
Alan Wake 2, I've heard, is pretty spooky, though.
It's spooky, but not your usual scary game.
But I've always wanted to try it, so...
Do the demos count?
They don't.
This BGM brings happy thoughts.
Yeah, it's called Lemon Cake, and it makes me always feel so...
You would like Urban Myth Disillusion Center.
Isn't that a visual novel?
Urban Myth Disillusion Center.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It is.
Is it law?
If you wanted to complete a game quickly, it would...
Ah, stop, stop!
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
That was so loud.
Go away!
Uh...
Wait, what?
Wisp made a game recently where you are on trial for murder.
The sloppy turnabouts!
What?
Why?
My birthday was on the 5th and I never got an opportunity to pop in and say hi blade happy birthday to you too page happy birthday happy birthday
why am i on try i'll think about it but right now i want to stick to spooky stuff spooky is the priority here but i'll figure something out um like i said i'll figure something out for uh the day that i'm trying to figure out something for and then i will Um,
have my schedule up tomorrow.
Yes.
But for now, thank you guys for...
Um, what happens when you don't finish enough games for the year?
Is there a punishment?
That I will finish enough games.
I will, I will!
Blackout Club for Kalam.
What's that?
Oh, it's expensive!
Oh, wait!
I think I've seen this game before.
Oh, I have seen this game before.
Why is it $30?
Anyway.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for today, for letting me try out some of these little funny demos.
And it was good.
It was good.
Oh, yeah.
Deadly Premonition.
I also have them on my list.
And I was also thinking of playing that one this week, starting it.
So maybe something, we'll see.
But I thought it was maybe too close to Silent Who.
So, thanks for the stream.
It was fun checking out all these games.
Thanks, Vikni.
Thank you, guys.
Choo, choo.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, Silent Zero.
Thank you.
Also, Pirate, I'm so sorry.
I missed yours.
When it releases, you can play this one with someone who is famously good with horror.
Which one?
Which game?
I had fun with the stream.
Thank you.
Wait, Deadly Permission is nothing like Silent Hill?
Oh, it's not.
I thought the combat was kind of similar.
I guess not.
I have, honestly, know so little about it.
I've tried to avoid every spoiler.
So.
It's like Twin Peaks.
I meant the, sorry, I meant like the fighting aspect.
Try to control the same people of Alan Wake.
Well, I don't know quite yet what I'm gonna do.
I'll figure it out.
But thank you for all the suggestions.
I get a little overwhelmed when people are always throwing out so much, you know?
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna go for real now, though.
I gotta go.
I'm gonna... I'm thirsty.
I have just a little bit of tea left.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
I will see you when I see you next Ita-da-shai, have a good day, have a good night, have a good time zone Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
I forgot to mention Um, I was given some Hold on, let me double check what they are I was given some Promotional codes?
Promotional codes for US Idol Festival That will be happening at the end of the month that I will be appearing at with a two meet and greets and a concert.
The promotional codes, I will probably do like a little raffle where you comment on Twitter or something and I maybe I'll do one on YouTube, one on, I don't know how many codes they give me.
But if I have multiple codes, I will do one on YouTube, like a community post and one on Twitter.
So just kind of keep an eye out for it but i'll do them later not tonight i'll mention again tomorrow or on another stream as well so yeah so if you don't have twitter you can comment on youtube and if you have both you can comment on both but you know yeah okay that's all i want to say